bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition de 24h Sénat la séance les
sénateurs s'intéressent aujourd'hui aux
comptes bancaires inactifs et aux
assurances VI non réclamé on va en
parler dans un instant avec Tam tranui
mais avant cela l'autre en fort de
l'actualité du Sénat aujourd'hui c'est
l'audition de Pascal lami par la
commission des affaires économiques
l'ancien directeur de l'OMC a livré une
vision sans concession de l'état de la
France je vous propose de l'écouter
quant au raisonnement sur l'Europe cadre
favorable aux autres et pas à nous
typique de cette
autolagellation française qui consiste à
penser qu'on est des mauvais qu'on est
des médiocres qu'on se fait avoir par
les autres et quand c'est pas la Chine
c'est l'Allemagne et quand c'est pas
l'Allemagne c'est Bruxelles et quand
c'est pas Bruxelles c'est les immigrés
quand c'est pas les immigrés c'est les
Arabes il y a toujours il y a toujours
une raison extérieure à nos problèmes
l'Allemagne et j'ai connu ça quand
j'étais à Bruxelles après la
réunification a connu des années
épouvantables l'Allemagne était l'homme
malade de l'Europe dans la même Europe
que nous
elle était malade plus rien allait comme
chez nous et puis qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont pas changé l'Europe pour ça
ils ont fait une opération qui s'appelle
standor Deutschland ils ont pris le
taureau par les cornes et ils ont petit
à petit réussi à résoudre un certain
nombre de leurs problèmes donc avec le
même cadre l'Allemagne est sortie de la
Moïse alors que nous n'en sommes pas
sortis donc ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
l'Europe qui est
responsable nous
avons nous
avons s'il vous plaît monsieur rotillo
pas de provocation nous avons mais nous
avons nous avons nous avons nos propres
problèmes reconnaissons-le et ne mettons
pas ces problèmes toujours sur le dos
encore une fois de cette mondialisation
de la Chine de l'Allemagne de Bruxelles
aussi longtemps aussi longtemps que nous
resterons dans cet état
d'esprit qui consiste à attribuer
l'essentiel de nos problèmes ailleurs ce
qui commode
intellectuellement notre pays continuera
la dérive qu'il a entamé il y a 40 ans
avec le déficit des finances publiques
qu'il a entamé il y a 30 ans avec le
chômage de masse et qu'il a entamé il y
a 10 ans avec la détérioration de sa
compétitivité le président du Parlement
georgien étaé reçu aujourd'hui par
Jean-Pierre belle le président du Sénat
avant d'être salué par l'hémicycle du
Sénat les deux hommes ont abordé la
situation en Ukraine il faut dire que la
politique étrangère russe inquiète les
georgien bien décidé à se rapprocher de
l'Union européenne on
l'écoute la Géorgie est bien décidée à
rejoindre une plus grande Europe notre
pays continue son chemin vers une
intégration à l'Union européenne et à
l'OTAN nous remercions particulièrement
nos collègues pour leur aide envers
notre jeune démocratie et nous
souhaitons continuer cette
coopération dans le même tempous av
évoqué l'Ukraine et la menace que
représente l'agression russe pour tous
les pays dans la région et en
Europe enfin nous avons répété une
nouvelle fois que la Géorgie fait partie
des pays qui essaie d'éviter les guerres
et qui essaie de stabiliser la situation
pour éviter l'escalade de la situation
et pour établir la paix et la stabilité
dans la
région et sachez que les sénateurs
communistes réclament au gouvernement
l'organisation rapide d'un débat sur la
sit sur la situation en Ukraine afin je
cite d'évoquer l'action de la diplomatie
dans la recherche de solutions pour
ramener dans ce pays la paix civile et
la stabilité je vous le disais le Sénat
examine cet après-midi une proposition
de loi sur la question des avoirs
bancaires non réclamés pour en parler on
va retrouver Tam Tran nuit en direct de
l'hémicycle du Sénat bonjour Tam bonjour
dalphine alors quel est le principe de
cette proposition de loi bien écoutez
l'objectif de ce texte est de mieux
protéger les épargnants car en cas de
décès il arrive que des comptes
bancaires que des assurances vie des
personnes décédées restent en désérance
qu'elle ne soit pas réclamé par les
ayants droits alors ce texte vient
apporter un certain nombre de solution
pour mieux informer les clients pour
mieux identifier les comptes bancaires
inactifs avec par exemple un tout
nouveau rôle he pour la caisse des dépôt
dans ce domaine mais il reste une lacune
une lacune essentielle c'est que les
banques ne sont toujours toujours pas
obligé avec ce texte de rechercher
d'éventuels héritiers comme c'est le cas
par exemple pour les assureurs alors les
assations les associations d'usagers
s'insurge pour elle c'est clair l'état
préfère sacrifier les usagers et garder
la main sur le magot un magot tout de
même de 1 milliard et demi d'euros car
sachez Delphine qu'au bout de 10 ans si
cet argent n'est pas réclamé et bien il
atterrit à la Caisse des dépôts et au
bout de 30 ans il devient tout
simplement la propriété de l'État merci
beaucoup mal sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle poursuivre cette séance et
on se retrouve tout à l'heure à
19h l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
relative au comptees bancairirees
inactif et au contrat d'assurance vie en
désérance dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Michel Sapin
ministre des Finances et des comptes
publics
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur
général Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et
sénateurs la situation des comptes
bancaires inactifs et des contrats
d'assurance vie en dshérance
constittuent aujourd'hui une injustice
qui a depuis de nombreuses années
mobiliser le Parlement tant à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'au
Sénat lors de la discussion sur le
projet de loi de séparation et de
régulation des activités bancaires il y
a donc un an le sujet des comptes
bancaires inactifs avait été soulevé et
mon prédécesseur Pierre moscovissi avait
indiqué qu'il soutiendrait une
initiative parlementaire sur ce sujet
qui concerne nombre de nos concitoyens
je m'inscris donc moi-même dans cette
démarche et redis tout le soutien que le
gouvernement apporte à cette proposition
de loi je me permets de de souligner
devant vous le travail approfondi
effectué avant que le travail ne soit
fait ici par la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale et
l'implication toute particulière de
Christian eert alors rapporteur général
et qui a souhaité que je sois celui qui
ici défendrait ce texte qui tient
beaucoup de sa substance et de son
intelligence à son propre
travail l'Assemblée nationale s'est
appuyée sur le travail de la Cour des
comptes qui a établi un diag fiable avec
un objectif double d'une part protéger
les clients et les épargnants ou leurs
ayant droits qui n'ont jamais réclamé
des fonds qui leur appartiennent
pourtant d'autre part protéger les
intérêts financiers de l'État à qui ces
fonds doivent être retournés au terme du
délai de prescription
trentenaire avant de développer ces deux
volets j'aimerais souligner à quel point
la résolution de ce problème don la
traduction en chiffre révèle l'ampleur
doit être une des priorités de l'action
publique dans son rapport établi à la
demande de la commission des finances de
l'Assemblée nationale la Cour des
comptes évalue le montant des encours
concernés à plus d'un milliard d'euros 1
milillard 200 millions d'euros pour les
comptes bancaires et plus de 2 milliards
7 d'euros pour les contrats d'assurance
vie et de capitalisation non
réclamé sur quoi porte le constat de la
Cour des comptes premièrement les
lacunes en matière de traitement des
avoirs en désérran qui porte atteinte à
la protection des épargnants et de le
leurs ayant droit d'abord parce que
ceux-ci ne sont pas en mesure
d'identifier les fonds dont ils ne
savent pas soit par oubli soit par
ignorance qu'ils en sont les
propriétaires légitimes
ensuite parce que les règles de
transfert à la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation ne sont pas assez claires
et sont donc mal
respecté deuxièmement le rapport
soulligne que l'État n'est pas
aujourd'hui en en mesure de faire
respecter son droit en matière de
recouvrement des avoirs frappés par la
prescription trentenaire les conclusions
du rapport de la Cour des comptes
confirme donc la nécessité de procéder à
des modifications législatives pour
assurer un traitement satisfaisant des
avoirs en
désérance le débat sur les avoirs
bancaires et les contrats d'assurance
vie en désérance dure depuis trop
longtemps et cette proposition de loi de
grande qualité enrichie par l'Assemblée
nationale et la commission des finances
du Sénat traite le sujet de façon
satisfaisante le premier volet de la
proposition relatif au compte bancaire
définit les comptes bancaires inactifs
dans le Code Monétaire et Financier
cette disposition comble une lacune du
cadre juridique applicable au compte
bancaire inactif qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui définis par la loi et sur
lesquels l'Autorité de contrôle
prudentiel et de résolution ne peut donc
exercer un contrôle
efficace le texte prévoit un ensemble d'
obligation à la charge des banques en
particulier une obligation de
consultation annuelle du répertoire
national d'identification des personnes
physique pour vérifier que le titulaire
du compte n'est pas décédé le
recensement des comptes inactifs et le
plafonnement des frais perçus ainsi que
l'obligation de transfert des fonds à la
Caisse des Dépôts la commission des
finances du Sénat votre commission des
finances a par ailleurs trouvé une
solution ad hoc pour la gestion du
contenu du coffre fort en déserant
c'est une solution pragmatique dont le
gouvernement se félicite beau sujet qui
révèle parfois beaucoup de surprises
dans son contenu autant un compte en
banque ne peut contenir que des
liquidités autant un coffre fort peut
contenir tout objet de toute nature le
texte a trouvé pour l'essentiel sur ces
sujets un bon équilibre je ne doute pas
que d'autres améliorations seront encore
apportés aujourd'hui s'agissant des
contrats d'assurance vie en déserrance
les premières avancées adoptées dans le
cadre du projet de loi de séparation et
de régulation des activités bancaires
répondaient en partie mais pas en
totalité à la question de la recherche
d'information des bénéficiaires la
proposition de loi prévoit ainsi de
nouvelles obligations portant sur les
assureurs dont le renforcement des
contrôles la revalorisation le
plafonnement des frais de gestion ainsi
que l'obligation là aussi de transfert
des sommes détenues à la Caisse des
Dépôts par ailleurs en complément des
obligations imposées au teneurs des
comptes la proposition de loi prévoit
d'organiser une consultation des
fichiers détenus par l'administration
fiscale recensant les comptes bancaires
le fichier FICOBA et les contrats
d'assurance fichier ficovi par les
notaire lorsqu'il règle une succession
elle offre également aux assureurs la
possibilité d'obtenir de
l'administration les coordonnées d'une
personne physique lorsque celle-ci est
le bénéficiaire d'un contrat d'assurance
vie dont l'assurée est décédée
il s'agit d'une garantie supplémentaire
pour éviter que les comptes ou contrats
ne restent en dshérance même si le
gouvernement en comprend la logique il
rappelle que ce dispositif pourrait
toutefois imposer une charge de gestion
importante au service chargé du contrôle
fiscal qui gère ces fisquers ces
fichiers enfin la commission des
finances du Sénat a étendu l'obligation
de revalorisation postmortem du capital
garanti au contrat d'assurance sur la
vie dépourvu de valeur de rachat
souscrit par des personnes physiques
telles que des assurances temporaires
décès cette extension a le mérite de
traiter de manière identique tous les
contrats d'assurance vie souscrit par
des des personnes physiques et d'éviter
que le retard de règlement des
prestations par un assureur ne se
traduis par un manque à gagner pour les
bénéficiaires autre point le texte
propose une solution efficace avec
l'obligation de transfert des fonds
après un certain un délai à la Caisse
des dépôts qui serait chargé de les
consigner jusqu'à l'application de la
prescription cette mission confier à la
Caisse des dépôts est essentielle et
permet de donner au nouveau dispositif
toute son efficacité en instaurant un
guichet unique ceci permet de préserver
là encore les droits des clients ou de
leurs ayants droits mais également
permet une application correcte et
diligente de la prescription trentenaire
en faveur de l'État en effet la bonne
application du principe de prescription
trentenaire devrait permettre à l'État
de percevoir Infiné les fonds dont les
propriétaires ne peuvent pas être
identifié le manque de diligence des
établissements de crédit et des
entreprises d'assurance ainsi que les
insuffisances de la législation actuelle
privent actuellement l'état de ces
recettes qui lui reviennent évidemment
de droit le gouvernement donne donc
entièrement raison à cette proposition
voilà donc Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs les enjeux de
cette proposition de de loi pour la
protection des clients qu'il soit
assurés ou épargnant et pour la
préservation des intérêts financiers de
l'État c'est un double objectif que le
gouvernement soutient
ardemment dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur François Marc
rapporteur de la commission des
finances monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
cet après-midi traite d'un problème qui
n'est pas
nouveau et auquel le législateur a
d'ailleurs tenté de remédier à plusieurs
reprises ces 10 dernières années il
s'agissait de mettre fin à un flou
juridique qui profitait surtout aux
établissements financiers et de protéger
tout à la fois les intérêts des
épargnants mais aussi ceux de l'État
la loi d'adaptation au droits
communautaire dans le domaine de
l'assurance de 2005 que Philippe Marini
alors rapporteur général avait rapporté
avait renforcé l'obligation pour les
assureurs d'aviser les bénéficiaires
d'un contrat d'assurance vie au décès de
l'assuré en mettant en œuvre tous les
moyens raisonnables pour les
retrouver c'est à cette occasion
qu'avait été créé l'association pour la
gestion des informations sur le risque
en assurance l' girira qui regroupe
l'ensemble des professionnels du secteur
et on sait qu'elle peut être saisie pour
tout part par tout particulier qui
souhaite savoir s'il est bénéficiaire
d'un contrat d'assurance vie dont
l'assuré est décédé et ce dispositif a
été sensiblement renforcé par la loi du
17 décembre 2007 qui a imposé aux
assureurs une obligation générale de
s'informer sur le décès éventuelle de
l'assurée couvert par un contrat
d'assurance vie ainsi qu'une
revalorisation des sommes
correspondante une proposition de loi
déposée depuis par notre collègue Hervé
Moret que je salue qui prévoyait
notamment une publication annuelle des
démarches effectuées par les assureurs
pour rechercher des assurés décédés
comme des bénéficiaires a ensuite été
adopté par le Sénat en avril 2010 elle
n'a toutefois pas été examinée par
l'Assemblée
nationale enfin l'an dernier la loi de
séparation et de régulation des
activités bancaires a prévu à
l'initiative du
Sénat que les assureurs s'aquittent au
moins chaque année de l'obligation de
s'informer du décès éventuel de leur
assuré sur la vie et publie un certain
nombre
d'information mais il faut pour autant
une nouvelle fois remettre l'ouvrage sur
le
métier et bien parce que ces différentes
initiatives n'ont pas permis de régler
le problème des contrats d'assurance vie
non réclamé et qu'il est nécessaire
d'aborder également la question des
comptes bancaires
inactifs une enquête commandée à la Cour
des comptes par la commission des
finances de l'Assemblée nationale
application de l'article 58 de la LOLF
et remise en juin
2013 en effet révélé les montants en
cause sont bien plus importants que ce
que l'on imaginait
jusqu'ici deux rapports remis par le
Gouvernement au Parlement en juin 2009
et juillet 2010 avait
estimé le montant des contrats non
réclamés à 1 milliard d'euros puis 1
milliard 2 il s'appuyait sur des données
fournies par les assureurs eux-mêmes qui
avaient tendance à minimiser le
phénomène on le sait bien la Cour des
comptes a estimé quant à elle que c
encours était de de ,76 milliards
d'euros et encore il s'agit selon elle
d'un minimum
et les éléments que j'ai recueilli
auprès de l'Autorité de contrôle
prudentiel et de résolution conduisent
aujourd'hui à envisager un montant qui
pourrait atteindre et peut-être dépasser
4,6 milliards
d'euros ce que ces montants révèlent au
premier chef c'est que le peu de
diligence que les assureurs ont mis à
s'informer du décès éventuel de leurs
assurés et à rechercher les
bénéficiaires des contrats il est vrai
qu'il n'avait aucun intérêt à rendre des
sommes que personne ne leur demandait et
que le contrôle du respect de leurs
obligations en la matière était jusqu'il
y a quelques mois encore très
limité ce faisant les bénéficiaires de
contrat qui n'étaient pas informés des
sommes leur revenant ont été laésés mais
aussi les contribuables euh la plupart
des assureurs n'ayant pas appliqué la
prescription 30 anenaire qui prévoit le
reversement à l'état des sommes non
réclamées après 30
ans suite au contrôle engagés par
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution des sanctions ont commencé à
être prononcées contre les assureurs
n'ayant pas respectter leurs obligations
légales il me paraît indispensable bien
sûr que ces contrôles se poursuivent et
que les sanctions des mangements sot à
la fois public et proportionné au
montant indûement perçu par les assur
qui ont pu être
considérabl je rappelle à cet égard que
la loi de régulation bancaire et
financière de 2010 a relevé à 100
millions d'euros le plafond de sanction
qui peut que peut prononcer
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution alors je me félicite bien
entendu que la commission des finances
et la commission pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois et décidé de
confier à nos collègues Philippe Marini
et Corine bouchou le soin de de procéder
à une évaluation des dispositions
législatives relatives au pouvoir de
sanction des régulateurs
financiers s'agissant des comptes
bancaires
inactifs la situation n'est pas beaucoup
plus
glorieuse la Cour des comptes en estime
l'encours à 1,5 milliards d'euros au
minimum comptte bancairirees
inactif surtout il n'y a pas moins de
660 14000 comptes bancaires aujourd'hui
détenus par des gens supposés être
centenaires
674000 comptes et ceci alors même qu'il
n'y a en France que 20000 personnes
âgées de 100 ans ou plus donc on voit
l'écart considérable
674000 comptes
bancaires pour seulement 20000 C
centenaire réellement en vie certes les
obligations des banques à l'égard de
leurs CLI ne sont pas les mêmes que
celles des assureurs alors que le
contrat d'assurance sur la vie a pour
objet même le versement d'un capital en
cas de décès ce qui implique de
rechercher et prévenir les bénéficiaires
le banquier quant à lui n'est tenu qu'à
ses obligations de restitution au
titulair des fonds qui lu sont confiés
c'est d'ailleurs un point sur lequel
nous aurons l'occasion deenir à
l'occasion de la discussion des
amendements il ne reste pas moins que
les banquiers appliquaient jusqu'ici
assez peu les dispositions concernant
les comptes en désérance les sommes
déposées volontairement à la Caisse des
Dépôts et Consignation comme celles
versées au Trésor au titre de la
prescription trentenaire sont restés
symboliques ces dernières années le fait
que ces avoirs constituent des
ressources stables au bilan des banques
et continuent de donner lieu à la
perception de frais parfois jusqu'à
épuisement des comptes n'y est sans
doute pas totalement étranger il me
paraissit nécessaire donc de faire ces
rappels peu flatteur pour nos
établissements financiers même si les
pratiques ont été variables car ce sont
les leurs manquements qui justifient
pour une large part une proposition de
loi beaucoup plus précis que les
principes et règles générales que nous
avions adopté jusqu'à
maintenant une nouvelle intervention du
législateur est donc nécessaire à la
fois pour traiter le stock considérable
d'avoir en deséran qui s'est constitué
et pour prévenir en outre son
aggravation et il convient dès lors de
saluer l'initiative de Christian eert
qui en s'appuyant sur l'enquête de la
Cour des comptes commandée par la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
nationale a déposé en novembre dernier
cette proposition de loi que nous
examinons
aujourd'hui alors votre commission des
finances a décidé de procéder à l'examen
conjoint de cette proposition de loi qui
a été adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale
le 19 février et de celle déposée par
notre collègue Hervé Moret qui travaille
depuis longtemps sur ce sujet les deux
propositions de loi poursuivent les
mêmes objectifs et puisent leur
asiration à la même source la commission
des finances a repris l'essentiel de
leur disposition tout en élargissant le
champ d'application de la proposition de
loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale si celle-ci a rencontré une
très large approbation au sein de la
commission c'est qu'elle franchit une
étape décisive par rapport aux
initiatives
antérieures en effet elle encadre de
manière précise les différentes étapes
conduisant après 30 ans et en l'absence
de manifestation de tout ayant droit
en dépit des informations et recherches
mis en œuvre à la prescription des
sommes au profit de l'État le dispositif
de la proposition loi s'organise ainsi
en 3 temps d'abord constat du décès de
l'assuré ou du caractère inactif du
compte bancaire à l'issue d'un délai
variable selon les situations mais qui
est façon majoritaire de 10 ans et bien
il y
a dépôt des fonds à la Caisse des dépôts
et consignations qui organise la
publicité de l'identité des titulaires
du compte ou du contrat et garanti le
reversement des sommes si leur
destinataire légitime se
manifeste enfin si personne ne se
présente transfèt à l'état en
application de la prescription
trentenaire alors cette mécanique de
précision qu'il est proposé de mettre en
place à une triple vertu tout d'abord
elle renforce la protection des
épargnants et des bénéficiaires de
contrat assurance vie en second lieu
elle conforte les intérêts financiers de
l'État en garantissant le respect de la
prescription centenaire trentenaire
pardon et enfin elle permet aux
professionnels en particulier les
assureurs de si l'on peut dire sortir
par le haut d'une situation qu'ils ont
certes contribué à créer mais qui leur
est devenu de plus en plus préjudiciable
au fur et à mesure où l'ampleur des
sommes en jeux et des dysfonctionnements
a été révélé ces toutes récentes années
les activités bancaires et d'assurance
vie essentielles à la sécurisation de
l'épargne au financement de l'économie
repose sur la confiance des épargnants
et le lancinant dossier des avoirs en
déserrance était de nature à entamer
cette confiance on l'a bien compris la
proposition de loi devrait permettre de
la rétablir je crois utile de vous
présenter à présent plus en détail les
principales dispositions de la
proposition de loi elle vient tout
d'abord combler une lacune de notre
droit en définissant ce qu'est un compte
inactif et le régime auquel il doit être
soumis un compte peut-être déclaré
inactif parce que son titulaire est
décédé dans ce cas les sommes sont
déposé à la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation au bout d'un délai que la
commission des finances a souhaité
porter de 2 ans à 3 ans à compter de la
date du décès si aucun n'ayant droit ne
s'est
manifesté la proposition loi oblige le
notaire chargé de la succession à
consulter systématiquement le fichier
des comptes bancaires le FICOBA afin
d'identifier l'ensemble des comptes
souscrits par le
défunt cela devrait à l'avenir réduire
le de manière très significative le
nombre de compte en dshérance à la suite
du décès de leur
titulaire un compte peut également être
déclaré inactif s'il n'a pas enregistré
d'opération depuis un an et que son
titulaire ne s'est pas
manifesté dans ce car le transfert la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation
intervient au bout de 10 ans
d'inactivité durant cette période les
établissements sont tenus de vérifi tous
les ans que le titulaire du compte
inactif n'est pas décédé par la
consultation du répertoire national
d'identification des personnes physiques
et le dépôt
intervient seulement après que la banque
a cherché à prévenir le titulaire à
différentes occasions définis par le
texte qui pose à cet égard des
obligations très précises enfin
point important la proposition de loi
instaore un plafonnement des frais
pouvant être prélevés sur un compte
inactif donc dans tous les cas les
sommes déposées auprès de la caisse sont
acquises à l'état à l'issue d'un délai
de 30 ans qui se décompte à partir du
décès du titulaire ou de la dernière
opération enregistrée sur le compte le
champ du dispositif est large puisqu'il
inclut tous les comptes d'épinte qui
sont considérés comme inactifs au terme
d'un délai de 5 ans
la commission des finances a précisé les
conditions de liquidation au terme du
délai de 10 ans des titres déposés sur
des comptes inactifs en substituant un
critère de liquidité à celui de la
cotation des titres ce qui permet
d'étendre l'application du dispositif
elle a aussi comblé un vide juridique en
adoptant un dispositif spécifique pour
la délicate question des coffrefort en
désérance comme pour les comptes
bancaires le dispositif concernant les
contrats d'assuran sur la vie ou de
capitalisation non réclamée s'organise
en trois étapes la proposition de loi
renforce au cours d'une première période
les obligations des d'information à la
charge de l'assureur et l'oblige à
respecter un taux minimal de
revalorisation
postmem du capital garanti en cas de
décès afin de l'inciter à retrouver les
bénéficiaires des contrats 2è étape au
terme d'un délai de 10 ans si les sommes
du n'ont pas été réclamées elles sont
versées à la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation qui assure la publicité sur
Internet de l'identité des des
souscripteurs des contrats en
Dérance et en 3oisème lieu au terme d'un
délai complémentaire de 20 ans les
sommes déposées sont acquises à l'état
si personne ne les a
réclamé voilà donc mes chers collègues
la commission des finances a souhaité
étendre
encore un peu plus le périmètre
d'application du
dispositif en premier lieu elle a étendu
au contrat d'assurance sur la vie ne
comportant pas de valeur de rachat par
exemple les assurances décès
l'obligation de comporter un mécanisme
de revalorisation postmortel du capital
garanti
ensuite elle a inclus ses contrats ainsi
que les bonds de ou contrats de
capitalisation au porteur dans le champ
du dispositif de dépôt à la Caisse des
Dépôts et Consignation enfin la
Commission des finan
propose de faire bénéficier l'ensemble
des contrats d'assurance sur la vie y
compris en cours du taux minimum de
revalorisation introduit par la
proposition de loi le texte comporte
plusieurs mesures destinées à faciliter
le règlement des contrats ainsi le
notaire chargé d'une succession sera
autorisé à interroger le futur fichier
des contrats d'assurance sur la vie le
ficovie sur mandat d'un bénéficiaire
éventuel ou pour identifier les contrats
de capitalisation souscrits par le
défunt dans le même esprit la commission
des finances a introduit des
dispositions visant à renforcer les
moyens de recherche et d'information des
assureurs en leur permettant de
bénéficier du concours de
l'administration fiscale et des
notaires la proposition de loi comme
vous le savez doit rentrer en vigueur au
1er janvier 2016 afin de laisser à
chacun le temps de préparer les outils
et procédures nécessaires à sa pe de
mise en œuvre
cela permettra également aux assureurs
d'accomplir avec diligence leurs
obligations de recherche et
d'information des bénéficiaires des
contrats qui sinon seront de fait
transférés à la Caisse des dépôts et
consignations ou acquis à
l'état voilà l'essentiel mes chers
collègues je vous proposerai tout à
l'heure un certain nombre d'amendements
visant à améliorer la rédaction du texte
élaborer en commission et à lui apporter
des précision utiles la proposition de
loi pourra également être complétée par
l'adoption de plusieurs amendements de
notre collègue Hervé Moret que la
Commission a validé sous le bénéfice de
l'ensemble de ces observations la
commission des finances vous invite à
adopter cette proposition de loi elle
n'est pas de nature à susciter des
clivages politique car elle fait je
crois œuvre utile en augmentant la
protection des épargnants et des
titulaires de compte bancaire et à
défaut des intérêts de l'État je vous
remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Vincent
Placé pour le groupe
écologie
pas
président monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre cher Michel Sapin monsieur
le rapporteur cher François Marc cher
Fabien cellerer mes chers collègues
cette proposition de loi s'attaque à un
sujet qui pouvait sembler marginal à
priori mais dont l'ampleur est en
réalité considérable ça vient d'être dit
c'est un véritable trésor que nous
détenons ici les chiffres avancés par la
Cour des comptes sont éloquentss
cellees-ci estime ainsi que les encours
qui entrent dans le périmètre de ce
texte sélèvent à 1,6 milliards d'euros
pour les comptes bancaires inactifs et
2,76 milliards d'euros pour les contrats
d'assurance vie plus de 670000 comptes
bancaires inactifs sont concernés par
les dispositions de ce texte tout
l'enjeu de cette proposition de loi
était de définir le périmètre des
comptes bancaires considérés comme
inactifs comme inactif ainsi que des
contrats d'assurance vie en désérance je
crois que les critères proposés ici sont
pertinents c'est pourquoi j'en
profiterai pour saluer le travail de
notre ancien collègue député rapporteur
général de budget devenu secrétaire
d'État chargé du budget
christianer reconnaî à ce texte trois
qualités majeures elle institue une
meilleure protection des intérêts des
épargnants et de leurs ayant droit une
meilleure garantie des intérêts de
l'État et témoigne d'un réel souci
d'encadrer les activités
bancaires la protection des droits des
épargnants titulaires de compte ou ayant
droit elle passe d'abord par un plus
grand suivi des activités du compte
ainsi que d'une meilleure connaissance
des conditions dans lesquelles un compte
bancaire est déclaré inactif
mais elle repose surtout sur un vrai
travail systématique de recherche et
d'identification des titulaires et des
ayant droit afin de garantir leur droit
de propriété sur les sommes en jeu ils
arrivent en effet trop souvent que les
ayant droit ne soient pas informé de
leur statut par les titulaires des
comptes notamment lors d'un décès avant
un décès bien sûr de fait il est de la
responsabilité de la banque ou de la
société d'assurance de faire son
possible pour identifier et informer le
nouveau titulaire pour se faire les
délais retenus de 10 et 20 ans soit 30
ans avant le transfert des sommes en jeu
à l'état me semble raisonnable nous
verrons dans la pratique s'ils
conviennent mais je suis assez confiant
sur ce
sujet dans un deuxième temps lorsque
tout a été mis en œuvre pour identifier
les titulaires des comp et des contrats
c'est évidemment à l'état que doivent
revenir les sommes et avoir non réclamé
je salue l'effort de cette proposition
de loi pour que soit pris en
considération les intérêts de l'État par
le biais de la prescription trentenaire
il est en effet indispensable d'assurer
que les fonds non réclamés au bout de 30
ans reviennent bien à l'État sont
garantis ici les intérêts des citoyens
non seulement en tant qu'épargnant mais
aussi en tant que contribuable car le
manque a gagné fiscal est financier pour
l'État est loin d'être négligeable
pourquoi dans ces moments de flottement
les banques profiteraiit-elle de la
situation fondamentalement cette
proposition de loi témoigne aussi de la
volonté de la majorité d'ailleurs de
l'ensemble des collèguesin j'ai
l'impression en effet comme l'a dit le
rapporteur général que une unanimité
consensuelle positive se se manifeste de
donc une volonté de tout le monde de
poursuivre son travail dans encadrement
des activités bancaires cela passe par
plus de transparence dans la gestion et
la restitution des comptes bancaires
inactifs et des contrats d'assurance VI
en Dérance notamment via un effort de
recensement des comptes inactifs et des
contrats non réglés mais cela se traduit
également par un plafonnement du montant
des frais et commissions prélevés par
les banques afin d'éviter des ponctions
trop importantes celles-ci atteignent
tout de même parfois plus de 60 % du
montant total des actifs inscrits euh
sur le compte ce qu'il faut éviter
par-dessus tout ce sont les abus et les
négligences disons-le commis par les
banques et les sociétés d'assurance je
le rappelle ces excès sont dommageables
pour les épargnants pour les
contribuables et pour les finances
publiques parmi ces excès je voudrais
également attirer votre attention sur
l'absurdité de continuer à prélever
automatiquement des frais sur des
comptes bancaires considérés comme
inactif du fait de l'absence d'écriture
de ligne pour les banques celle-ci
engage en réalité que des frais très
minimes pour la gestion de ces comptes
et ces frais sont en outre largement
compensés par l'accès aux liquidités
ainsi disponible et y compris d'ailleurs
les jeunes vivant à l'étranger les
personnes dépendantes ou malades sont
les premières victime de cette
perception injustifiée de frais à
laquelle nous proposons de mettre fin
par un amendement à l'article 1 je sais
que le groupe CRC a le même article je
sais qu'il fait débat je trouve dommage
qu'il n'y ait pas plus d'accord sur ce
sujet pour finir je me réjouis du
travail parlementaire que nous avons
effectué sur ce texte nous avons pu
nourrir ce débat et progresser dans
notre réflexion d'abord lors de l'examen
de la loi de séparation et de régulation
desactivité bancairire puis de la loi
sur la consommation nous avions
d'ailleurs retiré notre groupe à ce
moment-là notre amendement de
suppression des frais sur les comptes
bancaires inactifs après avoir obtenu la
la promesse du gouvernement que nous
évoquerions ce sujet ici va l'être
aujourd'hui donc je suis content de voir
qu'effectivement on va en débattre j'ai
constaté bien sûr que la promesse du
gouvernement d'en débattre ne voulait
pas dire que c'était euh un débat pour
aboutir hein j'ai bien j'ai bien noté
cela cette proposition de loi va dans le
bon sens celui de la reconnaissance des
droits des épargnants et des intérêts de
l'État et en cela semble faire consensus
parmi nous je m'en réjouis c'est un fait
suffisamment rare pour être remarqué et
apprécié c'est aussi une forme je crois
une force ici du bicamérisme et
d'utilité du Sénat vous l'aurez compris
le groupe écologiste votera en faveur de
ce texte qui marque une avancée attendue
essentielle en matière d'encadrement des
activités bancaires et de renforcement
des droits et je me félicite de nouveau
de l'excellent travail de christianert
des collègues de l'Assemblée et ici du
Sénat avec le rapporteur général et
notre nouveau ministre des Finances que
je salue merci à
vous dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Francis de lâre pour le groupe
UMP monsieur le Président Monsieur
monieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le rapporteur général vient de le
rappeler ce texte inscrit dans le
prolongement d'un grand nombre de
dispositions législatives qui n'ont pas
tous produit les effets escomptés
puisque après les lois de 2003 2005 2007
nous sommes obligés de compléter un
arsenal qui n'a pas donné totalement
satisfaction en réalité les
établissements financiers n'ont pas
toujours joué le jeu ne se sont pas
empressés en tout cas à le jouer mais je
dois dire aussi que l'Assemblée
nationale a omis aussi de de reprendre
une proposition de loi de notre collègue
Hervé Moré qui avait été ici adopté au
Sénat en 2010 et qui n'a jamais été
inscrit à l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale donc c'est un souci largement
partagé monsieur le ministre
elle allait pourtant dans le même sens
que la présente proposition rappelons
également que lors de la discussion du
projet de séparation et de régulation
des activités bancaires au printemps
dernier votre prédécesseur s'était
engagé naturellement et engagé le
gouvernement d'aboutir sur ce dossier
dans le cadre d'un texte
spécifique le texte dont nous discutons
aujourd'hui est donc l'établissement
l'aboutissement d'un long processus il a
été naturellement depuis euh enrichi par
les travaux de la Cour des comptes de
juin 2013 et a fait l'objet je pense
depuis d'une large concertation avec
toutes les les parties prenantes avec
Bercy la caiss des dépôts mais aussi
l'établissement bancair les compagnies
d'assurance les notaires les
généalogistes et aussi les représentants
des épargnants le résultat de ce travail
et de cette concertation est donc
largement consensuel et dépasse
aujourd'hui naturellement les clivages
habituels le texte concilie à la fois
l'intérêt général à savoir les intérêts
financiers de l'État les intérêts
particuliers en l'occurrence la
protection des droits des épargnants et
de leurs oit même si sur ce point des
progrès restent encore à faire et nous y
reviendrons un peu plus tard notamment à
travers les
amendement l'article 1er constitue un
apport substantiel par rapport au droits
positifs en élargissant la problématique
de l'assurance vie en deséran au compte
bancairire inactif dont il précise et
c'est une novation très utilement la
définition les enjeux sont importants et
les chiffres qui ont été rappelés aussi
bien par Monsieur le Ministre que par le
rapporteur général en témoigne même si
l'estimation des montants diversge
l'essentiel et qui sont très conséquents
représentant plusieurs milliards d'euros
de fonds d'ORM sur des comptes bancaires
ou des assurances vie non seulement ces
fonds constituent des ressources
quasiment gratuites pour les
établissements financiers car en
l'absence de mouvement sur le compte les
coûts de gestion pour les banques sont
très faibles voire quasiment nuls mais
de sur cro des frais sont parfois
prélevé sur ces comptes d' dormant si
les livrets réglementés ne subissent
aucun frais tel n en ralité pas le cas
des comptes courants ils sont par
exemple de 50 € à la Société Générale 82
€ chez LCL au cré lonnais et ça monte
jusqu'à 135 € au Crédit du Nord ces
prélèvements de frais bancaires sur des
comptin actif peuvent même à longueur
d'année vider carrément les comptes en
question le peu d'empressement de
certains établissements à la fois à
rechercher les aendroits et à appliquer
la prescription
trentenaire rappelons qu'on regard de
ces milliards d'ormands seulement 50
millions d'euros en 2012 au titre des
comptes bancaires inactifs sont revenus
dans les caisse de l'État et un peu plus
de 6 millions d'euros de 2008 à 2012 au
titre des contrats d'assurance vie ces
milliards seraiit pourtant regard
surtout du contexte actuel monsieur le
ministre bien plus utile à la fois finan
publi ou dans le patrimoine de nos
compatriotes qui en sont les ayant droit
plutôt que de dormir plus ou moins dans
les comptes dans des établissements
financiers dont on ne connaît pas
d'ailleurs la tout à fait la nature
juridique entre les fonds propres quasi
fonds
propres est-ce que ça arrête dans dans
les critères de balle 2 de balle 3 il y
a un flou juridique intéressant cela ne
remettrait d'ailleurs nullement en cause
la ration de solvabilité de ces
établissements les milliards d'euros
contenus dans les 18 millions de comptes
bancaires inactifs estimés ne représente
en effet que 1 % de l'encours total des
établissement bancaires et les 2 à 4
milliards d'euros de contrat d'assurance
vie en désérance représentent moins de
0,5 % des encours totaux de l'assurance
vie c'est pourquoi nous nous réjouissons
que l'obligation faite dans ce Tex de
transférer à la casae des dépôts au bout
de 10 ans les sommes non réclamées des
contrats d'assurance vie ou des comptes
bancaire inactif au bout de 2 ans les
sommes non réclamées après le décès du
titulaire d'un compte permettra de
garantir l'application la prescription
trentenire puisque la Caisse des Dépôts
elle ne serait manqué de respecter
scrupuleusement le transfert à l'état
des fonds non réclamés
elle sera de toute façon contrôlée par
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution l'obligation de transfert
préalable des fonds non réclamés à la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation va
également dans le sens de la protection
des épargnants et leurs ayant droit
puisque la caisse garantit l'intégralité
du capital ne prélevement aucun frais
elle sur celui-ci en outre elle devra en
faire une publicité en ligne et c'est la
principale novation de garantie via un
site sécurisé qui permettra TX etendroit
de plus facilement retrouver la trace
des fonds qui leur sont dus cette
publicité conforte la position du
Médiateur de la Caisse des Dépôts
qui comme la Cour des comptes a dénoncé
l'insuffisance du dispositif d'alerte
des épargnants ou des héritiers sur le
mécanisme de déchéance trentenire au
profit de l'État en principe pourtant le
le potentiel bénéficiaire doit être
prévenu par courrier recommandé 6 mois
avant le transfert à l'état mais un
courrier même envoyé à une mauvaise
adresse suffit à être considéré comme
une information de l'ay drroit sans
retour possible de l'aggent transféré de
l'argent transféré au trésor
le dispositif d'alerte des titulaires de
compte inactif paraît bien léger peu
importe que l'adresse soit erronnée et
que le courrier ne soit pas arriver à
son destinataire la présente proposition
de loi va permettre de renforcer
considérablement les obligations
d'information mais cela semble encore
insuffisant dans une première lecture
c'est ce que nous avons tous considéré
et certains amendements défendus par nos
collègue Jean-François hon et Hervé Moré
tel que sousamondé par notre commission
et monsieur le rapporteur général sur sa
proposition pourrait monsieur le
ministre utilement compléter l'arsenal
de protection des épargnants et des
héritiers par exemple en informant le
titulaire d'un compte de sa
qualification de compte inactif sans
attendre les 6 mois avant sa
transmission à la Caisse des Dépôts mais
également en obligeant les banques à
rechercher les héritiers connus par
exemple les enfants du titulaire décédé
client de la même banque en revanche il
paraît plus compliqué de demander aux
banques de rechercher lesendroits non
connus à contrat des assureurs qui eux
sont censés inscrire dans les contrats
les bénéficiaires au surplu lors des
successions les notaires ont
l'obligation désormais de consulter le
FICOBA qui est le fichier recensé
l'ensemble des comptes bancaires les
héritiers sont ainsi informés de
l'existance ou non en tout cas ils
peuvent l'êre de compte alors pas tous
les tous les héritiers parce qu'il y a
il y a 20 % des décès qui n'entraînent
pas de l'ouverture d'une succession mais
c'est quand même une avancée
intéressante la proposition de loi
prévoit par ailleurs d'autres avancées
appréciables avant l'formation par la
CAE des dépôts le texte propose
également d'instaurer un recensement
annuel de l'ensemble des comptes
inactifs dans les établissement
bancaires afin de garantir plus de
transparence aux aux épargnants seront
précisés leur nombre et leurs montants
lorsqu'un compte est considéré comme
inactif l'établissement tenant ce compte
en informe le titulaire sans nouvell de
sa part il doit alors consulter le
répertoire national d'identification des
personnes physiques pour vérifier une
chose importante si le titulaire est
toujours vivant de la même façon les
assureurs quant à eux n'auront plus la
faculté instauré en 2007 mais désormais
l'obligation de consulter chaque année
le répertoire national d'identification
des personnels physiques pour identifier
les titulaires de contrat d'assurance
vie décédés
cette recherche des personnes décédées
va ainsi éviter la
situation assez narrative dans laquelle
monsieur rapporteur général a cité lui
les centenaires alors moi je vais citer
les nonagéir ils sont 600000 dans notre
pays et il y a un 2 million de comptes
bancaires à leur nom alors on voit bien
qu'il y a là vraiment une vraie
difficulté un vrai problème alors une
fois la formation du décès du titulaire
enregistré il s'agit alors de trouver en
fait ces aant drroits potentiels nous
avons vu que pour les établissements
bancaires en succession il leur serait
difficile de rechercher des endroits
inconnus mais dans le cas de l'assurance
vie si les bénéficiaires sont censés
être indiqués se pose le problème
récurrent du manque de précision souvent
de leur adresse de leur identité et
cetera la responsabilité des compagnies
d'assurance est de ce point de vue
indéniable rappelons qu'elles ont le
devoir de conseil de l'assurance en
matière de désignation des bénéficiaires
d'un contrat d'assurance sur la vie et
que ceci a été rapporté récemment dans
un arrêt de la Cour d'appel de Paris du
8 octobre
2013 la recherche des bénéficiaires des
contrats en désirance leur incombe et
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel entend
désormais en contrôler à la fois le
caractère et la diligence il y a un mois
elle a ainsi prononcé un blâ monsieur le
ministre assorti d'une sanction de 10
millions d'euros à l'encontre de Cardif
une filiale d'assurance de BNP parib qui
avait tardé à rechercher les
bénéficiaires de contrat d'assurance vie
non réclamé gageons que l'exemplarité et
l'application réelle de ce pouvoir de
sanction va inciter l'ensemble des
compagnies d'assurance à se conformer à
leur obligation de recherche concernant
le problème des frais bancaires avant le
transfert désormais obligatoire au bout
d'un certain délai des fonds non
réclamés des comptes inactifs à la
Caisse des dépôts qui n'applique elle
aucun frais ou commissionnement le
problème est également résolu par
l'introduction d'un plafonnement des
frais bancaires prélevés sur ces comptes
abandonnés dont le montant sera fixé par
décret en outre aujourd'hui pour une
banque un compte inactif susceptible
d'être facturé en tant que tel est en
réalité un compte non mouvementé pendant
1 an dans la proposition de loi la
banque devra désormais prendre en compte
l'ensemble des comptes du tuttelaire
pour établir l'inactivité et pour un
compte d'épargne il faudra attendre non
pas un an mais 5 ans après le dernier
mouvement pour le le déclaré inactif
nous le voyons des avancées certaines
ont été proposées dans le projet que
nous examinons aujourd'hui c'est pour
ces raisons et pour toutes ces raisons
que notre groupe le groupe EMP votera
cette proposition de loi relative au
comptte bancaires inactif et au contrat
d'assurance vie en désérance et nous
pensons par exemple à l'extension aussi
de ce projet de texte au coffre fort
abandonné qui a été repris par des
amendements à la commission des finances
tout en souhaitant l'adoption de
certains amendements de nos collègues
que j'ai cité qui renforceront un peu
plus les épargons et leurs etendroit
voilà Monsieur le Ministre VO ça
monsieur le Président l'ensemble des
raisons qui nous amèneront à soutenir et
bien sûr la discussion des amement qui
ne leur mettra pas en cause ce projet
qui nous paraît urgent et utile
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé Moret
pour le groupe udi
UC monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues le 29 avril 2010 à cette
tribune présentant ma proposition de loi
relative au contrat d'assurance vie non
réclamée je citais la célèbre phrase de
boilot attez-vous lentement et sans
perdre courage 20 fois sur le métier
remettez votre ouvrage polissez-le sans
cesse et le repolissez elle illustrait
selon moi la nécessité d'avancer dans ce
domaine avec détermination pour garantir
enfin en une réelle protection des
épargnants mais de manière progressive
et par la même prudente pour ne pas pour
éviter d'être stoppé net par les lobby
ces propos étaient hélas exacts
puisqu'il a fallu plus de 3 ans pour que
cette proposition de loi qui n'était
qu'une étape soit adopté et encore
seulement partiellement aujourd'hui nous
devons examiner un nouveau texte issu de
la proposition de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale le 19 février et
de celle déposée par mes soins le 28
novembre 2013 l'amélioration des droits
des épargnants est en effet un long
cheminement engagé depuis près de 10 ans
dans le domaine de l'assurance vie le
législateur s'est à plusieurs reprises
saisi de ce sujet notamment en 2005 en
obligeant les assureurs à informer les
bénéficiaires s'ils étaient avisés du
décès du souscripteur et en permettant à
toute personne se croyant bénéficiaire
d'un contrat d'interroger un organisme
spécialisé c'était la naissance de la
girira 1 et en 2007 en obligeant les
assureurs à s'informer sur les
l'éventuel décès des souscripteurs âgé
de plus de 90 ans et dont le contrat
était supérieur à 2000 € et également
les obligé à rechercher le cas échéant
les bénéficiaires c'était la néance de
la Gira 2 l'application de ces textes a
cependant été tardive limité et de toute
évidence
insuffisante cette situation ne me
semblait pas tolérable ni d'un point de
vue éthique parce qu'il n'est pas normal
que des sommes déposées ne profitent pas
à leur bénéficiaires ni d'un point de
vue économique et fiscal pu puisque ces
sommes sont naturellement plus utiles
lorsqu'elles sont réinjectées dans
l'économie aussi j'ai déposé en 2009 peu
après mon élection une première
proposition de loi adoptée à l'unanimité
par le Sénat le 29 avril 2010 elle
visait principalement à obliger les
assureurs à s'informer chaque année du
décès éventuel de tous les souscripteurs
sans les conditions qui étaient
précédemment énoncées améliorer la
transparence sur l'état du stock des
assurances vie et à renforcer la
transparence sur les flux en obligeant
les assureurs à à rendre compte chaque
année des recherches effectuées à défaut
d'examen par l'Assemblée nationale cette
proposition a été une première fois
reprise dans le projet de loi relatif à
la consommation qui n'a malheureusement
jamais été adopté définitivement en
raison des échéances de 2012 elle a
ensuite été partiellement intégré dans
la loi de séparation et de régulation
des activités bancaires en juillet 2013
à l'exception notable et j'y reviendrait
des dispositions relatives à la
transparence sur les
flux dans le même temps il m'avait
semblé utile de m'intéresser à la
question de la désérance des produits
d'épargne des comptes bancaires et du
contenu des coffres forts c'était le
sens d'une question orale que j'avais
posée le 22 février 2012 et dans
laquelle je dénonçais l'absence de cadre
législatif définissant ce phénomène et
permettant à forciori d'évaluer son
ampleur le gouvernement de l'époque
s'était déclaré prêt à examiner les
moyens d'améliorer le dispositif
existant malheureusement aucune
initiative n'était intervenue depuis
c'est donc donc avec intérêt et
satisfaction que j'ai accueilli et pris
connaissance du rapport de la Cour des
comptes rendu sur le sujet en juillet
2013 dans ce rapport la Cour estimait au
minimum à 1,2 milliards d'euros l'encs
des avoirs bancaire non réclamé et celui
des contrats d'assurance vie et de
capitalisation à au moins 2,76 milliards
d'euros une enquête plus récente de
l'Autorité de contrôle prudentiel et de
résolution parle même de 4,6 milliards
pour les seuls contrats d'assurance vie
vous le voyez on est très loin du
chiffre annoncé par les assureurs en
2009 qui était selon eux bien inférieur
à 1 milliard ce constat sans appel sur
l'ampleur du phénomène l'attitude des
assureurs et des banquiers et les
carences du cadre législatif m'ont
conduit à déposer une nouvelle
proposition de loi en novembre
2013 celle-ci visait essentiellement à
étendre aux avoirs bancaires la démarche
engagée depuis 2005 pour les assurances
vie et à complété le cadre lislatif
relatif aux assurances vie en renforçant
la transparence et en prévoyant
notamment la
revalorisation postmortem elle reprenait
également cette proposition de loi
quelques mesures pratiques suggérées par
la Cour des comptes t que l'obligation
pour les notaires de consulter le
FICOBA cette proposition de loi été vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur
général pour l'essentiel satisfaite par
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
et je me félicite notamment que la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui apporte un certain nombre de
solution à la question des comptes
inactifs mais aussi à l'initiative de
notre commission aux assurances d'cè au
contenu des coffres forts des bons et
des contrat de capitalisation je me
félicite qu'une définition précise du
compte inactif soit enfin établie que
les frais de gestion soient plafonnés et
qu'une revalorisation postmortem des
contrats soit garantie dès le décès à un
taux minimum fixé par décret je me
réjouis également que des outils soit
mis à disposition des professionnels
dans le cadre du règlement des
successions que soit mis un terme à la
pratique Scand aleuse qui conduisait
certains professionnels à réclamer
toujours de nouvelles pièces ou des
pièces identiques pour retarder le
règlement des contrats et enfin que le
rôle de la CPR soit
renforcé je suis satisfait pour
l'essentiel mais je dois l'avouer
monsieur le rapporteur général pas en
totalité en effet je trouve je trouve
que si ce texte a l'immense mérite
d'éviter que les banques et les sociétés
d'assurance conserve des avoirs inactifs
30 ans grâce à leur transfert à la
Caisse des Dépôts il ne pose pas
clairement l'obligation de recherche des
titulaires ou des ayants droit qui n'est
prévu que pour les contrats d'assurance
vie je souhaite donc sans oublier la
nécessité que j'évoquaé tout à l'heure
d'avancer progressivement dans ce
domaine que que nous allions dès
aujourd'hui un peu plus loin c'est la
raison pour laquelle je proposerai
d'étendre l'obligation de recherche au
titulaires des comptes et des
coffreesforts inactifs dans la procédure
de droit commun visé à l'article 1er par
qu' aujourd'hui elle n'est prévue que
pour les contrats d'assurance vie et
dans le dispositif provisoire prévu à
l'article 12 je considère que sans une
réelle recherche préalable le transfert
des avoirs inactifs n'apporte pas de
réelle protection supplémentaire aux
épargnants le transfert ne peut-être
qu'un ultime recours sinon il
s'apparente à un holdop des épargnants
en ce qui concerne l'article 12 je ne
suis pour ces raisons déjà énoncées pas
favorable à sa philosophie alors que
l'Acpr a commencé enfin à prendre des
sanctions contre les assur
pour les négligences et les fautes
intentionnelles dans la gestion des
contrats en désérance le transfert
général à la Caisse des dépôts et à
l'état prévu à l'article 12 dans l'année
qui suit l'entrée en vigueur c'est à
partir du 1er janvier 2007 dédoinerit
largement les assureurs de leur
responsabilité dans la gestion de ce
scandale il délaisseraiit à bon compte
les assureurs de leur responsabilité il
leur permettrait pour reprendre le thème
du rapporteur général que je cite de
sortir par le haut d'une situation
qu'ils ont contribué à créer
et surtout il leur permettrait
d'échapper au risque de sanction
pécunière par la PCR je rappelle que
récemment 10 millions d'euros d'amende
ont été infligé à une société que
j'aurais la charité de ne pas citer ce
n'est évidemment pas acceptable et je
souhaite donc qu'il y ait une obligation
de recherche et pour que celle-ci puisse
s'eectuer dans de bonnes conditions je
proposerai de décaler légèrement la date
de transfert je souhaite également que
la transparence qui a été améliorée par
ce texte sur les stocks le soit aussi
sur les flux cette transparence sur les
flux qui était déjà dans ma proposition
de loi de 2010 est indispensable car
elle permet de mesurer les efforts
engagés par les assureurs les banquiers
année par année pour résorber ce
phénomène pour celles et ceux de nos
collègues qui n'auraient pas eu
connaissance du rapport de la Cour des
comptes le constat qu'elle dresse est
sans appel il y a eu volonté claire de
ne pas appliquer ou de n'appliquer que
très partiellement la loi de 2007 et le
président Marini lors de l'examen de ce
texte en commission a d'ailleurs fait ce
constat je le cite il faut croire que
nous avons été siciamment trompés et
bien oui nous avons été siamment trompés
et je doute pas dans ces conditions de
la volonté de notre assemblée de
renforcer la transparence je souhaite
enfin introduire dans ce texte un
dispositif permettant d'être informé sur
ce que l'on nomme les NPAI c'est-à-dire
les courriers retournés à l'expéditeur
avec la mention n'habit pas à l'adresse
indiquée chaque année les banquiers et
les assureurs reçoivent de nombreux NPI
parce que l'adresse du du destinataire
est mal renseignée du fait d'un
changement d'adresse ou comme je l'ai
moi-même vécu à titre personnel parce
que l'adresse a été mal enregistré à
l'origine combien d'envois sont
concernés quelles actions sont menées
pour retrouver les destinataires de ces
courriers c'est-à-dire les bénéficiaires
de ces contrats nous n'en savons rien
alors que de toute évidence des
recherches précises permettraient de
retrouver les destinataires et de
limiter par la même le risque de perdre
tout contact avec le le titulaire ou le
bénéficiire d'un compte d'un coffre fort
ou d'un contrat l'objet de ma démarche
mes chers collègues c'est la protection
des épargnants celle de notre collègue
éert et peut-être même du gouvernement
dont il fait aujourd'hui partie me
semble plus attentive aux effets sur les
finances public du transfert des sommes
conservées par les assureurs et les
banquiers à cet égard l'étude d'impact
prive les parlementaires d'une
estimation des montants qui seraiit
transféré à la Caisse des dépôts et à
l'état en application de l'article 12 et
j'espère monsieur ministre que vous
pourrez nous donner quelques éléments
chiffrés sur ce point tout à l'heure
alors en conclusion je voudrais vous
rappeler comme le soulignait le premier
président de la Cour des comptes lors de
son audition à l'Assemblée nationale je
le cite que les personnes les plus
susceptibles d'être touché par la
désérance sont celles qui détiennent les
plus petits dépôts bancaires c'est pour
eux et pour eux seuls que nous devons
travailler aujourd'hui car si au terme
de nos travaux l'argent des avoirs
inactifs ne fait que passer des livres
des comptes des banques et des
assurances à ceux du Trésor l'intérêt
sera le moins que l'on puisse dire
réduit pour l'épargnant c'est pourquoi
je souhaite mes chers collègues que
l'examen de ce texte permettre de
renforcer cette protection à défaut les
nombreuses avancées qu'il contient
aurait un goût amer et je ne suis pas
certain de pouvoir l'accepter je vous en
remercie dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à monsieur Éric
Boquet pour le groupe
CRC
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
madame président de la commission chers
collègues nous sommes aujourd'hui en
débat pour examiner une proposition de
loi qui tente sous certains aspects de
clore un débat entamé avec la loi sur la
séparation bancaire débat relatif à la
gestion des avoirs endormis dans les
écritures de nos établissements de
crédit et de nos compagnies
d'assurance même si par essence n conna
iss son pas tout à fait les montants en
jeu nous disposons cependant ainsi que
le rappel le rapport au fond de quelques
éléments de mesure de l'ampleur du
phénomène un phénomène mise à jour lors
des précédents débats sur la profession
bancaire que nous avons pu avoir dans
cette enceinte et qui motive à la
lecture du contenu des des amendements
adoptés en commission comme de ceux
déposés en vue de l'examen en séance
publique un assez large accord sur la
nécessité de mettre un terme à des
pratiques qui devraient au demeurant
avoir déjà disparu depuis longtemps
le débat que nous avons est au fond
assez proche de par ces enjeux de celui
relatif à l'assurance crédit puisqu'on
parle de plusieurs milliards d'euros
d'en cours enregistrés au crédit des
comptes inactifs et des contrats
d'assurance dit en
dshérance une somme qui représente à la
fois peu au regard des montants des
sommes chaque année collecté par nos
établissements de crédit par exemple
mais en même temps beaucoup même si les
sommes sont d'un montant relativement
dérisoire au regard de Cell qui passent
et repass pass sur les écritures de nos
banques et de nos compagnies d'assurance
on ne peut oublier que plusieurs
milliards d'euros de ressources
gratuites constituent toujours un levier
plutôt rémunérateur pour les
établissements intéressés d'autant que
nos banques par exemple continuent
d'encaisser quelques frais de gestion
sur des comptes dont le calme et
l'inactivité sont pourtant le lot
étonnante pratique qui consiste à
récupérer des frais sur les titulaires
de comptte parfois un peu trop actifs
jusqu'à se retrouver à découvert comme
sur les comptes où rien ne se passe
l'affaire porterait sur quelque chose
comme environ 3 milliards d'euros somme
que l'on ne peut évidemment s'empêcher
de rapprocher de l'encs des comptes
créditeurs estimés à fin février dernier
à hauteur de plus de 487 milliards
d'euros en clair nous parlons de quelque
chose qui pèse pour moins d'un point sur
les comptes créditeurs de nos
établissements bancaires et encore moins
au regard de l'encours total des dépôts
bancaires des clients en France qui
dépassaient lui fin février les 1600
milliards d'euros en pratique les
banques prélèvent des frais sur des
comptes inactifs dont le montant
constitue 0,2 % de l'encours mensuel
moyen des dépôts pour revenir au texte
qui nous préoccupe ce jour nous
souhaitons évidemment qu'il soit adopté
nous y contribuerons quand bien même
conviendrait-il d'y apporter quelques
utiles précisions notamment sur la
notion de comp inactif notion qui fait
parfois débat nous pensons pour notre
part que l'inactivité d'un compte
bancaire bien même est-elle constaté par
les systèmes de gestion d'un
établissement de crédit ne peut-être que
le fait du titulaire même du compte nous
avons décidé d'amender le texte en ce
sens et j'ai d'ailleurs constaté avec
intérêt que ce souci de précision était
largement partagé sur les B de notre
assemblée la même observation vaut pour
les contrats d'assurance vie et il
importe pour notre part que la question
de la démarche de recherche des yendroit
soit précisé autant que faire ce peut et
les responsabilités des compagnies
d'assurance clairement sétabli des
avancées sont produites par le contenu
des articles du texte mais il nous
semble que d'autres doivent encore être
accomplis notamment du point de vue du
contrôle de l'activité des compagnies en
tout état de cause il est évident que
l'adoption ainsi amendée de la présente
proposition de loi permettra de
compléter le nécessaire effort de
transparence et de modification des
pratiques bancaires et assurancielles
entamées depuis 2 ans la lecture du
rapport de notre collègue rapporteur
général est particulièrement riche
d'enseignement en est fait sa lecture
nous apprend que certains établissements
de crédit ont été défaillants sur
l'application de certaines règles de
gestion sont cités et pointé notamment
l'identification des comptes inactifs
voir l'absence totale d'identification
de ces comptes la communication de la
cour des compte est tout aussi explicite
quant aux obligations de certains
assureurs qui ont été de leur côté
également défaillant c'est le mot
utilisé je me permettrai monsieur le
rapporteur général de citer ici votre
rapport dont la lecture est compris d'un
sujet financier comme celui-ci peut
parfois prêter à sourire je cite la part
anormalement élevée des centenaires
parmi les assurés de la vie dont
certains battent tous les records de
longévité est un signe particulièrement
révélateur de ces dysfonctionnements fin
de citation on cite dans le même rapport
le manque de diligence de certains
assureurs à s'acquiter de leurs
obligations de recherche et
d'information des bénéficiaires d'un
contrat je conclurai avec un dernier
point cet inventaire à la prêvre après
notre collègue Moret qui cétait boilot
en citant cette PHAs du rapport qui met
clairement en cause l'autorité de
contrôle prudentiel et de résolution en
tout cas jusqu'à 2011 sur l'insuffisance
des contrôles effectués sur le respect
des obligations des assureurs autrement
dit ce projet de loi devrait aider à
clarifier la gestion des comptes et
contrats en dshérance toutefois je pense
que notre démarche ne serait pas
complète si nous n'appelions pas à la
plus grande vigilance quant aux
responsabilités des établissement
bancaires et des assureurs aucun maillon
de la chaîne ne doit être défaillant nul
doute d'ailleurs que la situation dont
nous débattons aujourd'hui aurait un peu
moins de prignance si notre secteur
financier et assuranciel était investi
de mission de service public dans un
rôle exclusif de financement de
l'économie réelle le projet de loi dont
nous débattons ce jour ne constitue
certes pas un enjeu fondamental de la
nécessaire régulation des activités
financières toutefois il peut très
modestement et contribuer chacun
mesurant ici à quel point il reste aux
politiques entre guillemets beaucoup de
chemins à parcourir pour encadrer avec
beaucoup de rigueur et d'efficacité les
activités financières afin de toujours
les orienter vers l'intérêt de
l'économie du réel et de nos concitoyens
je vous
remercie dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Jacques mzard pour le groupe
RDSE
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il ne
s'agit pas de la fermeture d'une niche
financière c'est plutôt l'ouverture
d'une caverne d'Alibaba où les 40
voleurs sont identifiés de longues
dates le rapporteur à juste titre avec
sa précision
habituelle rappeler le nombre de comptes
bancaires théoriquement détenus par des
centenaires aujourd'hui en France le
meilleur moyen de se survivre c'est
d'avoir des comptes bancaires c'est ce
nous confinons là à l'éternité de la
meilleure manière qu'il
soit on pourrait pour ces
674014 centenaires se réjouir de la
longévité de nos concitoyens et pourtant
il semblerait mais mais Linc aussi nous
le savons comme élus locaux se trompe
souvent il semblerait quand même qu'il
ne soit que 20000 on est donc loin du
compte et même à raison de plus d'un
compte bancaire par personne et si nous
avons sans doute des milliers d'heureux
et riches centenaires nous avons surtout
de nombreux bénéficiaires qui se
retrouvent privés de sommes figurant sur
des compte dont ils n'ont pas
connaissance on peut faire à peu près le
même constat pour les contrat
d'assurance vie en dshérance
c'est-à-dire dont le titulaire ne se
manifeste pas et n'est pas localisable
ou dont le titulaire est décédé et pour
lequel aucun ayant droit ne s'est
manifesté nous savons tous ce qu'il en
est il faut dire que il faut bien la
conjugaison des forces de la Cour des
comptes de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat pour tenter de vaincre la
résistance de la finance monsieur le
ministre
on peut aussi considérer qu'en ce qui
concerne les montants concernés s'ils
sont difficiles à évaluer ils sont
colossaux quand je vois les efforts que
nous déployons parfois pour essayer
d'aller vers des économies de quelques
millions d'euros et que l'on voit là
l'importance des sommes dont il s'agit
on se rend compte de l'importance du
sujet 1,2 milliard d'euros sur les
avoirs bancaires non réclamés entendus
comme inactif depuis moins au moins 10
ans et les contrats de d'assuranou de
capitalisation non réglée on nous dit un
peu plus de 4 milliards et demi d'euros
c'est donc quelque chose de considérable
et et pour raeler les choses par leur
nom c'est un des vrais scandales de la
République même si les assureurs
contrairement aux banques sont déjà
obligés de s'informer du décès de leurs
assurés et de rechercher les
bénéficiaires en pratique ces
obligations sont imparfaitement
respectées et les sanctions qui étaient
jusqu'à présent très RAR étai aussi
jusqu'ici peu dissuasive je crois que
les amendements qui vont nous être
présentés auront toutes leur utilité
pour améliorer la situation de nos
concitoyens il faut souligner que le
cadre juridique actuel sur ces avoir
inactif est loin d'être optimal et et
même pti de faiblesse structurelles ça a
été souligné l'enjeu de cette
proposition de loi est donc de corriger
cette situation et nous nous réjouissons
qu'elle puisse aboutir j'allais dire
enfin l'une des principales faiblesses
des dispositions législatives et
réglementaires actuelles et l'absence de
définition des comptes bancaires
inactifs la constatation de l'inactivité
repose en pratique sur l'appréciation de
chaque établissement de
crédit si si on demande au braconnier
d'élaborer les règles de braconnage il
est évident que c'est plus facile à
réaliser cela ne peut pas être
satisfaisant le premier mérite du texte
est donc d'inscrire dans la loi une
définition des comptes
inactifs le texte établit par conséquent
une obligation pour les établissements
de crédit de recenser ses comptes
inactifs ils devront pour cela procéder
à la recherche des personnes décédées
parmi leurs titulaires de compte avec la
consultation du répertoire national
d'identification enfin ils seront dans
l'obligation de procéder au transfert
des avoirs de ses comptes inactifs à la
Caisse des Dépôts ce qui est un progrès
tout à fait évident 3 ans après le décès
du titulaire et au bout de 10 ans pour
les autres cas
d'inactivité l'encadrement du devenir
des
avoirs de la constatation de
l'inactivité à l'application de la
déchéance 30enaire à l'issue de laquelle
les sommes confié dans un premier temps
à la Caisse des Dépôts reviennent à
l'état et la deuxième avancée principale
et significative de cette proposition de
loi le texte prévoit un dispositif
similaire pour les contrats d'assurance
vie en dshérance et je remercie le
rapporteur d'avoir complété et renforcé
le dispositif par les amendements qu'il
a fait adopter en commission pour
élargir le champ des contrats
d'assurance vie concerné et d'autre part
pour créer un régime spécifique des
coffres for inactifs la notion même de
confrefort inactif est très
parlante l'article 7 bis qui oblige les
notaires à consulter le fichier des
comptes bancaires et le fichier des
contrats d'assurance vie dans le cadre
du règlement des succession contribuera
à réduire considérablement les comptes
inactifs et les contrats d'assurance vie
en désérance dont les sommes doivent
être systématiquement restitué à leurs
bénéficiaires alors on sait très bien
que ce qui se pass c'est absolument
lamentable il faut bien dire que c'est
une responsabilité collective depuis de
très longues années au final ce texte
devrait donc permettre de rendre à quiis
de droit les avoirs des comptes inactifs
ou les contrats d'assurance vie en desan
au lieu de voir ces montants
ponctionnés parfois réduits à néant par
la perception de frais de gestion par
les banques ou les
assurances et on a d'ailleurs parfois
dans la vie quotidienne la la surprise
de se faire dire par un établissement
bancaire mais vous pouvez pas ouvrir tel
type de livret parce que vous êtes
titulaire dans notre compte et bien
monsieur le ministre arrivé récemment
pour des proches quand on cherche à
retrouvver le compte en question je peux
vous dire que c'est encore
aujourd'hui un parcours d'obstacle et
que y compris la Banque Postale parce
que c'est souvent le cas sur des CCP ne
fait pas preuve de diligence
exceptionnelle c'est donc dans l'intérêt
des épargnants et de leurs ayants droit
que nous soutiendrons ce texte mais
aussi dans celui de l'État et des
finances publiques ce texte en
définissant ce qu'est un compte inactif
en créant de nouvelles obligations pour
les établissements bancaires en
élargissant et précisant celle des
assureurs en renforçant les contrôles et
les sanctions en encadrant strictement
le devenir des sommes concerné constitue
une avancée indéniable pour les
épargnants pour leurs ayant droit et
leurs bénéficiaires ainsi que pour les
comptes publics c'est pourquoi
unanimement tous les membres de mon
groupe lui apporteront leur
soutien dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Jacques Chiron du groupe
socialiste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Monsieur Madame la
vice-présidente monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues l'objet de la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui intéresse depuis longtemps
le Sénat il y a déjà 4 ans le Sénat
avait discuté le texte alors proposé par
notre collègue
Hervé Moret l'an dernier le sujet avait
de nouveau été abordé lors de l'examen
du projet de loi de séparation et de
régulation des activités bancaires c'est
d'ailleurs parallèlement à l'examen de
ce projet de loi que nos collègues
députés dont Christian Ecker vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le ministre ont
exprimé le souhait que soit examiné
rapidement la question des avoirs
bancaires et des contrats l'assurance en
Dérance ils avaient sollicité on l'a dit
en ce sens la Cour des comptes dont le
rapport rendu en juin 2013 relevait des
lacunes tant de la part des
établissements financiers que de
l'État le constat fait par la Cour était
édifiant on l'a tous se rappelé d'une
part l'encadrement insisant des banques
et des assureurs laisse au moins 4
milliards d'euros non réclamés par les
tutilaires et les et les ayant droit 1
milliard 5 dans la trésorerie parce que
c'est ça qui est important des
établissements bancaires et 2 milillard
7 dans la trésorerie des
assureurs ceci contribue à expliquer
certaines disproportions vous l'avez
tous souligner les 675 comptes qui
auraient des des titulaires
recentenaires alors qu'il y a que 20000
personnes de cet âge en France mais
aussi les 1,3 millions de comptes
bancaires de titulaires ayant entre 90
et 100 ans parallèlement à cette
insuffisance garantie du droit de
propriété des épargnants la cour
soulignait que la prescrip prescription
trentenaire au terme de laquelle les
avoirs non réclamés doivent être
reversés à l'État n'était que très
partiellement
appliqué seul 29 millions d'euros ont
été versés à la Caisse des dépôts et
consinuation alors qu'on parle du 4
milliards sur la période
2006-2012 la proportion de loi déposée
par le groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale vise donc à assurer tant la
garantie des droits des titulaires
bénéficiaires ayant droit que la
protection des intérêts financiers de
l'État notre commission a adopté le
texte la semaine dernière en faisant
siennes les amendements parfois
substantiels de notre rapporteur dont je
tiens à saluer ici le travail la
présente proposition de loi offre en
premier lieu des garanties essentielles
pour les titulaires de comptes bancaires
ou des contrats d'assurance vie et leur
ayant droit elle renforce pour cela la
protection déjà existante pour les
contrats d'assurance vie et en crè une
pour les comptes bancaires qui n'en
avaient pas ce rapport de la Cour des
comptes relevait en effet que
l'encadrement juridique des contrats
d'assurance vie n'était que très
partiellement appliqué en particulier
les assururs tarde à mettre en œuvre
l'obligation faite par la loi du 17
décembre 2007 de consulter le registre
national des personnes physique la loi
du 26 février 2013 avait renforcé cette
obligation de consultation mais cela ne
F ne suffisait probablement pas la Cour
des comptes relevait en effet que les
identifié par les assureurs grâce au
registre national d'identification des
personnes physiques ne porte que sur les
décès d'assurer âgé de plus de 90 ans et
ou dont le montrant du contrat est
supérieur à 2000 €. je me je me félicite
donc que la PPL impose une consultation
annuelle aux assuraires qui devront
également publier un état annexé à leur
compte retraçant le nombre et l'encs des
contrats non réclamés de la même manière
l'obligation d'information annuelle
détaillé pour les seuls contrats de plus
de 2000 € instauré par la loi du 1er out
2003 laisserait hors du champ de très de
très nombreux contrats qui tombent
d'autant plus facilement dans l'oubli
pour cette raison nous nous réjouissons
que la présente proposition de loi
étende cette obligation à tous les
contrats d'assurance vie quel que soit
leur montant la loi de 2007 avait
surtout rendu oblig la revalorisation du
capital garanti 1 an après le décès du
souscripteur la Cour des comptes
relevait cependant que cette obligation
qui n'impose aucun niveau minimal de
revalorisation se traduisait par une
revalorisation postmortê du capital
moins élevé que la rémunération du
capital avant le décès c'est vrai qu'ils
en avaient moins besoin c'est pourquoi
l'article 4 de de la PPL pose le
principe d'un seuil minimal de
revalorisation du capital
garantie en cas de décès notre
commission a adopté la semaine dernière
un amendement essentiel de François
marque qui vient élargir le bénéfice de
l'obligation de revalorisation et du se
minimum à l'ensemble des contrats
d'assurance vie en cours et à venir si
si le régime des contrats d'assurance
vie était incomplet alors là celui des
comptes bancaires était quasiment
inexistant en premier lieu toute
tentative de protection se à l'absence
de définition du compte inactif un
compte sera donc désormais considéré
comme inactif en l'absence d'opération
ou de ou de manifestation du titulaire
pendant 1 an sur l'ensemble des comptes
détenus dans un même établissement
bancaire 5 ans pour les livrets et
compte à terme en cas de décès du
titulaire le compte est déclaré inactif
1 an après celui-ci en l'absence de
toute réclamation par les par par les
par les a en droit ça paraît tout à fait
logique sur la base de cette définition
les établissement teneur de compte
devont publier chaque année le nombre et
l'en cours des contrats inactifs
maintenus dans leur livre et assurer la
conservation des informations relatives
à ses comptes les frais de gestion
seront plafonnés de manière à garantir
les droits des ayants droit sur le C
capital conservé ou en leur
absence naturellement les droit de
l'État conformément à une recommandation
du rapport de la Cour des comptes la PPL
rend également obligatoire la
consultation par les notaire du FICOBA
dans le cadre d'une succession ces accès
centralisés et directs devraient limiter
le nombre de comptes non réclamé la PPL
consacre également la jurisprudence
récente qui permet aux ayant droit de
consulter ce fichier l'examen au Sénat a
je le crois permis de répondre à une
question laissée en suspens par par nos
collègues députés celles des
coffresforts la nature était différente
et celle des de celle des comptes
bantaires et il fallait concevoir un
régime particulier et celui proposé par
Fran sois Marc me paraît
ingénieux un coffre est inactif si deux
critères cumulatifs sont remplis aucune
manifestation du client pendant 10 ans
et le constat d'un loyer impayé 20 ans
plus tard la banque pourra disperser le
contenu du coffre pour se rémunérer des
frais générés mais le reste est sera
àquis à l'état et c'est-à-dire étonnant
de voir que les banques avaient fait
construire à la périphérie de Paris des
bâtiments spécifiquement pour mettre des
des des coffres forts qui n'étaient pas
qui n'avaient pas été visités depuis 30
40 ans on était quand même dans un
système excessivement spécial he bon
sinon spécieux 20 ans plus plus plus
tard donc si le principal objectif de
cette proposition de loi est de protéger
les épargnants elle assure également la
sauvegarde des intérêts financiers de
l'État ces deux préoccupations se
rejoignent d'ailleurs pour justifier la
mission confiée à la Caisse des Dépôts
et Consignation la PPL met en effet en
œuvre la préconisation phare du rapport
de la Cour des comptes qui consiste à
confier la gestion de long terme des
comptes inactif à la Caisse des dépôts
et consignuation et réaffirme ainsi le
rôle historique de conservation des
dépôts par la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation suite à un amendement
adopté par la commission la semaine
dernière le transfert des avoirs
bancaires inactifs à la Caisse des
dépôts et consinuation se ferra vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur à
l'issue d'un délai de 3 ans suivant le
décès du titulaire et non plus de deux
comme initialement prévu ou à l'issue
d'un délai de 10 ans suivant le début de
la période d'inactivité du compte
la caisse devra d'une part organiser la
publication de l'identité des titulaires
des comptes qui lui ont été transféré
afin de faciliter la recherche des
comptes inactifs et de protéger le droit
despargnants et d'autre part garantir la
valeur du capital déposé auprès d'elle
en et en en en limitant les frais de
gestion on a beaucoup insisté sur ce
fait le rôle de conservation des des
dépôts est également confirmé pour les
contrats d'assurance vie je suis
persuadé chers collègues que ce texte
consensuel comme en témoigne le faible
nombre d'amendements déposés permettra
de rétablir la transparence et la
confiance nécessaire en matière
d'épargne même si je note que la
Fédération française des banques et la
Fédération française des sociétés
d'assurance ont apporté tout récemment
leur soutien à cette initiative dans des
communiqués de presse ils avaient
peut-être mieux à a proposé certains
actes avant hein bon hein je me réjouis
surtout que ce soit le Parlement et le
gouvernement par la loi qui permett de
renforcer une confiance détériorée ces
dernières années de façon significative
et souvent légitime entre les Français
et leurs établissements financiers tout
en protégeant l'intérêt de l'épargne je
souligne également que grâce à ce texte
l'état protège ses propres intérêts fin
financiers est dans une période
financièrement difficile avec une
nouvelle recette potentielle de
plusieurs milliards d'euros en
complément des dispositions prises dans
ce texte voté par le
Parlement l'année dernière relatif aux
activités bancaires en parallèle des
mesures relatives à la fraude fiscale
qui ont été prises par le gouvernement
suite à des propositions de de rapport
d'enquête
parlementaire c'est un nouveau pas en en
avant vers une régulation nécessaire et
un contrôle effectif des établissements
bancaires depuis ces dernières années
vous l'avez souligné chers collègu nous
avons et souvent avec une large majorité
fait des avancé dans ces domaines mais
il n mais il nous faudra continuer à
persévérer pour plus de transparence et
encore plus d'efficacité
merci discussion générale est close nous
passons à la discussion du texte de la
Commission à l'article 1er je suis saisi
d'une demande de parole de Madame
Patricia Bordas groupe
socialiste monsieur le
Président Monsieur le monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre je tiens
à prendre la parole sur cet article afin
de vous faire faire part de la déception
de nombreux sénateurs socialistes qui
avaient souhaité déposer un amendement à
l'alinéa 26 de cet article 1er
amendement qui est tombé sous l'
l'arbitraire de l'article
40 comme vous le savez les sénateurs
socialistes travaillent depuis longtemps
sur les questions relatives à la perte
d'autonomie à cet égard nous sommes
singulièrement préoccupés par les enjeux
de son financement
en particulier nous avons tous en
mémoire les débats sur l'affectation du
produit de la Casa lors des derniers
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour rappel cette
contribution est destinée à financer la
réforme sur l'autonomie des personnes
âgées via une affectation à la Caisse
nationale de solidarité pour l'autonomie
dans l'attente d'une loi future en 2013
cette contribution a été affectée au
fond de solidarité vieillesse cela
devait rester une exception exception
qui a pourtant été reconduite par la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014 pour autant il est
inconcevable que l'exception devienne la
règle cependant par un amendement déposé
en commission des affaires sociales
l'Assemblée nationale a réussi à
maintenir l'affectation des 100 millions
d'euros à la CNSA à afin d'anticiper le
financement des premières mesures de la
loi à venir amélioration de la pas à
domicile modernisation des épages
mesures de prévention néanmoins il e été
préférable d'affecter cette ressource à
une réforme qui nécessite
indiscutablement un effort financier
substantiel ainsi aujourd'hui nous
examinons la proposition de loi relative
au compte bancaire inactif et au contrat
d'assurance vie en
désérance monsieur le ministre
lors d'une audition à l'Assemblée
nationale à l'époque où votre collègue
Christian etert était rapporteur général
du budget il a suggéré la possibilité
d'utiliser ces fonds pour des opérations
liées à l'investissement dans le domaine
de la dépendance je le
cite s'agissant de fonds parfois issus
de personnes âgées ou décédées ne
pourrait-on pas imaginer qu'une partie
des sommes puisse être employé pour des
opérations liées à l'investissement dans
le domaine de la
dépendance il y a actuellement de gros
besoins et peu de disponibilité
financière dans ce domaine je souhaite
donc qu'on puisse réfléchir avec
pragmatisme sur la possibilité de voir
là une opportunité d'emploi je viens de
citer monsieur
ekert et c'est précisément le point que
nous aimerions soulever afin de préparer
au mieux l'examen futur du projet de loi
d'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement de la population et parce
que les sources de financement sont
rares nous ne pouvons faire l'impass sur
aucune
opportunité le défin amendement que le
sénateur mon collègue George labazé a
déposé et qui a été Cigné par de
nombreux sénateurs membres de la
commission des Affaires social et par de
nombreux présidents de Conseils Généraux
visés juste justement à utiliser les
sommes de ses comptes bancaires inactifs
au financement des dépenses liées à
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie monsieur le ministre
nous sommes tous attachés à la réussite
du grand chantier de l'autonomie et par
certaint intervention j'entends
témoigner de la forte mobilisation des
sénateurs socialistes sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs il nous a paraît fondamental
que le gouvernement face montre de sa
détermination à mener à bien cette
réforme qui est l'un des enjeux des
défis majeurs auxquels nous sommes
confrontés nous devrons y répondre
collectivement en veillant à ce que les
les efforts soient justement partagé en
respectant le principe d'équité pour
cette raison monsieur le ministre nous
aimerions avoir l'engagement du
gouvernement quant à l'affectation de
cette manne au financement de
l'autonomie au sein du prochain proet de
projet de loi pardon de financement de
la sécurité sociale il me semble que ce
serait un signal fort du gouvernement au
moment où le contexte économique se
relève se révèle pardon particulièrement
contraint et les ressources financières
rares telle est la pierre que les
sénateurs socialistes souhaitent
apporter à l'édifice de la réforme sur
l'autonomie conformément me semble-t-il
aux orientations générales fixées par le
président de la la République je vous
remercie bien monsieur le ministre vous
souhaitez répondre à madame
bornas monsieur le Président Mames
messieurs les sénateurs nous aurons dans
le l'occasion en parlant des amendements
d'aborder les quelques sujets mais ce
que je remarque c'est qu'il y a une très
grande convergence des opinions exercées
et exprimées dans cet hémicycle
oui oui mais sur mes textes ça m'arrive
aussi de temps en temps donc je je le ça
avec d'autant plus de en connaisseur de
cause ou en connaissance de cause madame
sur la question que vous me posez je
reviens pas sur la question de de
procédure et juridique c'est un choix
qui appartient en l'occurrence à la
commission des finances et qui a
appliqué en l'occurrence les règles
applicable mais sur le fond des choses
je voudrais vous dire combien je suis et
ça ne vous étonnera pas en accord avec
ce que Monsieur Christian ert lorsqu'il
était rapporteur général du budget a pu
dire et vous avez cité ces termes donc
je n'ai pas besoin de de les
redire à nouveau je pense que la bonne
manière de faire en sorte que ces fonds
ou une partie de ces fonds puissent
aller vers des actions en faveur des
personnes qui sont dans un
vieillissement qui est une bonne chose
dans son principe mais qui pose un
certain nombre de problèmes c'est par le
biais de la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation parce que dans un premier
temps ces fonds vont aller à la Caisse
des Dépôts et Consignation il faut
attendre longtemps avant qu'ils arrivent
dans le budget de l'État et donc je
m'engage conformément ce qui avait été
d'ailleurs souhaité par chrisanert à
voir avec la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation si cette partie-là des
fonds qu'elle aura à gérer et qui seront
placés sous sa responsabilité puissent
être utilisé pour appuyer soutenir aider
au financement d'investissement en
l'occurrence d'investissement en faveur
des personnes de grand âge ce sera la
contribution en quelque sorte de cette
partie-là de ce texte et de ses fonds à
cette préoccupation à cette grande
préoccupation qui devra trouver par
ailleurs sa traduction dans le texte
texte auquel vous avez fait
allusion bien je suis saisi
d'un amendement à l'article 1er le 1
rectifié bis qui n'est pas défendu j'ai
donc l'amendement 32 qui est présenté
par Monsieur boet
oui très très simplement l'amendement
que nous posons donc a trait à la
définition du compte inactif donc qui
est un sujet don nous avons commencé à
débattre et nous voudrions samplifier la
définition en supprimant donc la fin de
l'alignée a 7 hors inscription d'intérêt
et débé par l'établissement tenant le
compte de frais et commission de toute
nature pour nous en tenir à le compte
n'a fait l'objet d'aucune opération donc
dans la période de 12 mois au cours de
laquelle et cetera et cetera nous
pensons
qu'effectivement un compte inactif ne
peut l'être que enfin peut être actif
que par la volonté du titulaire du
compte d'une part et que nous préférons
des règles claires qui sont selon nous
plus difficiles à contourner que des
règles complexe plus elles sont
complexes plus on s'ingénie àer
contourner l'expérience le montre donc
nous voulions apporter cette
contribution sous la forme de cet
amendement euh considérant que les
sommes restées en crédit des comptes
inactifs constittuent qu'on le veuille
ou non une ressource gratuite pour
l'ensemble de nos banques et euh nous
pensons enfin que la loi n'est pas faite
uniquement pour répondre aux attentes de
des établissements bancaires il nous
semble même qu'elle doit viser à
défendre d'abord et avant tout les
intérêts du plus grand nombre
c'est-à-dire de ceux de leur clientèle
je vous remercie
est l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur général merci monsieur le
président la commission est défavorable
à cet amendement car nous avons noté que
quelque part il
restreignait le cas d'inactivité des
comptes bancaires et et qu'il limitait
aussi la portée protectrice du
dispositif bien que nous comprenions que
cet amendement est un complément d'un
amendement ultérieur visant à supprimer
tout fraise et commissions sur les
comptes inactifs cependant chers
collègues tel que que rédigé il pourrait
avoir pour conséquence que ces
prélèvements empprêcheraient le constat
d'inactivité du compte et les banques
pourraient ainsi continuer indéfiniment
à procéder à ses prélèvements sans que
ne s'enclenche jamais le dispositif
protecteur de transfert la casae des
dépôts et dans ces conditions la portée
pratique de cet amendement ne me semble
donc pas en conformité avec l'inttention
qui était la vôtre et dès lors il serait
sans doute opportun de le retirer si
sinon je ne peux donner qu'un avis
défavorable à cet amendement invite du
gouvernement Monsieur le
Ministre Président je crains que à ce
stadelà en tous les cas de la procédure
et contenu de l'écriture de votre
amendement vous n'aboutissiez à une
situation peut-être contraire à celle
que vous souhaitez vous restreignez
ainsi le champ et vous risquez de
d'aboutir à ce que un compte ne soit pas
considéré enfin comme inactif pour les
raisons que peut-être vous n'avez pas
souhaité donc je je crain que vous arriv
à quelque chose qui n'est pas conforme à
votre souhait profond donc si vous
pouviez le retirer je pense que ça
m'éviterait de donner un avis
défavorable l'amendement est retiré les
deux amendements suivants ne sont pas
défendus donc j'en arrive à l'amendement
40 rectifié
bis qui est
présenté par Monsieur Husson
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
à travers cet amendement on vous propose
dans le droitfil d'ailleurs de nos
débats de nous intéresser non seulement
je dirais aux personnes décédées mais
aux aantroit en complétant donc l'alinéa
12 qui fait pour qu'il soit fait
obligation pardon de rechercher les
ayants droits ce qui nous paraîtêtre une
mesure je
dirais juste et je sais Monsieur le
Ministre
que votre prédécesseur d'ailleurs
l'avait reconnu les ayant droit qui
s'ignor par définition ne peuvent être
en mesure de réclamer les fonds censés
leur revenir de droit
et en ne prévoyant pas d'obligation de
recherche approfondie à la charge des
établissement bancairirees on pourrait
craindre parfois que les établissements
bancaires ne mettre pas en
œuvre tous les moyens leur permettant de
répondre à l'obligation voulue par
législateur et ça a été dit de manière
convergente ce qui donc ne répondrait
pas à l'objet souhaité cette amendement
faut-il le présir répond en plus à une
exigence constitutionnelle conforme à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyens et puis peut-être enfin je
crois
qu'il faut être re vigilant sur le droit
de propriété qui est aussi un droit je
dirais consacré par notre Constitution
et en tous les cas permettre aux
bénéficiaires ou aux ayants droit euh
d'avoir la certitude que les
établissements bancaires auront conduit
avec diligence et tout le savoir-faire
qu'il sont en mesure de produire de
manière générale il y a pas de raison de
douter moi je ne suis pas forcément
comme mon collègue Mar qui tout à
l'heure expliquait que les braconniers
n'étaient pas forcément ceux qui
allaient donner les solutions je crois
qu'il faut être un peu plus objectif et
reconnaître quand ça ne va pas quel que
soit l'auteur si c'est un professionnel
de l'erreur et bien ça vient de lui mais
j'entends aussi ce que banquiers ou
assureurs nous donne comme élément pour
parfois argumenter à leur profit
certains dans certains cas en tous les
cas la défense des
intérêts de des situations qui peuvent
leur poser problème c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas toujours simple
pour une raison d'ailleurs assez
évidente c'est que et on le verra avec
les assureurs les modalités de
souscription d'un certain nombre de
contrats il y a 10 15 20 ou 30 ans ne
demandez pas avec autant de précision
que ça le cas aujourd'hui d'éléments en
tous les cas administratifs nous
permettant d'avoir une
traçabilité quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général sur cet amendement merci
monsieur le Président cet amendement est
le premier d'une série
qui conduisent à
engager une recherche des ayants droit
par les banques et ceci sur une base
obligatoire donc la question s'est posée
au sein de la commission des finances de
savoir s'il fallait aller dans cette
direction et nous avons le sentiment que
ceci ne se révèle pas opportun pourquoi
bien parce que nous avons d'abord noté
que la proposition de loi en question
prévoit déjà de nombreuses nouvelles
obligations à la charge des banques
notamment la recherche des personnes
décédées par la consultation du
répertoire national d'identification des
personnes physiques l'information
systématique des
titulaires le transfert à la Caisse des
Dépôts et
Consignation le plafonnement des frais
d'inactivité la publication du nombre et
du montant des comptes concernés et
cetera en outre la recherche des ayants
droit serait très difficile à mettre en
œuvre par les banquiers parce que
contrairement aux bénéficiaires
mentionnés dans le contrat d'assurance
vie s'agissant des comptes bancaires les
ayant droit ne sont pas mentionnés
puisque c'est un simple contrat entre un
déposant et sa banque et
euh le banquier a comme ça seu
obligation la restitution à l'égard du
seul titulaire comment procéder dans ce
contexte à la recherche des enoit dont
ils ne connaissent même pas le nom enfin
je rappelle que le dispositif mis en
place par le texte notamment
l'obligation de consultation du FICOBA
par les notaires devrait largement
permettre de régler le cas des ayants
droit non informer de l'existence d'un
compte du défunt et dans ces conditions
euh il nous a semblé à la commission des
finances qu'il ne paraissait pas
opportun d'aller dans le sens souhaité
par cet amendement ainsi que par celui
de Monsieur Atenau qui était dans la
même dans le même esprit donc c'est un
avis défavorable monsur le ministre avis
du gouvernement
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Sénateur je vais donner un avis qui
est parfaitement comparable à celui qui
vient d'être donné par la rapporteur du
budget mais je crois que nous allons
reparler de ce sujet plusieurs fois donc
je essayer d'exprimer mon opinion
jusqu'au bout en fait vous faites une
comparaison
entre ce qu'il advient des cas
d'assurance d'assurance vie avec ce qui
peut advevenir des cas des comptes
bancaires on peut comprendre cette
volonté de parallélisme mais en fait il
s'agit vraiment pas du tout de la même
chose c'est pas de même nature
d'ailleurs c'est ce que la Cour des
comptes lorsqu'elle a été saisie a bien
souligner qui considérait que il ne
convenait pas d'imposer aux banques de
rechercher lesux enroits d'un en décédé
pour les raisons qui viennent d' dit on
connaît pas forcément celui qui en sera
le bénéficiaire du point de vue du droit
héréditaire cette obligation elle
incombe au notaire le notaire a
l'obligation de rechercher à l'occasion
du défunt quel est le bénéficiaire
potentiel par héritage de ce compte
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une assurance vive
vous le savez bien le bénéficiaire
peut-être quelqu'un d'autre qui n'est
pas celui qui serait le bénéficiaire par
héritage voilà les raisons pour la
laquelle euh même si on comprend tout à
fait vos préoccupations il ne me paraît
pas opportun de tirer de ce parallélisme
un parallélisme qui aille jusqu'à
imposer les mêmes obligations dans un
cas et dans l'autre voilà Monsieur le le
sénateur donc je comprends tout à fait
cela peut-être souhaitez-vous maintenir
jusqu'au bout votre position mais si
éventuellement cont tenu des
explications du rapporteur général et de
mes explication vous pouviez retirer ces
amendements je pense que ce serait
bienvenu
oui monsieur
oui monsieur le ministre je je ne vous
suis pas je vais vous expliquer en
quelques mots la raison pour laquelle je
vous suis pas d'abord parce que vous
essayer de de d'entraîner ou de
m'entraîner sur un paralélisme entre les
contrat d'assurance vie et les comptes
bancaires mais de plus en plus
aujourd'hui par le mode de vie qui est
le nôtre notamment le fait qu'il y a
moins de mariage que les gens vivent en
couple que il y a le il y a ou pas de
documents je dirais juridiqu vous pouvez
avoir aujourd'hui aujourd'hui un compte
à de noms sans être forcément lié par un
acte ni notarié ni d'état civil ce qui
veut dire que les imprimés dont les
compjoints enfin les imprimés des
banques les imprimés administratifs à
mon avis aujourd'hui répondent
effectivement là je vous rejoins
peut-être peut-être moins bien que
certains contrats d'assurance vie pour
lesquels on désigne des bénéficiaires
mais vous savez j'auraiis l'occasion d'y
revenir tout à l'heure c'est pas
toujours facile de les trouver il
n'empêche que selon moi le problème
demeure y compris sur la question des
enroit parce que vous pouvez aussi avoir
une convention passé alors si elle est
passée devant notaire en général
forcément à la suite d'un décès ça se
SAA pour l'acte notarié le fichier qui
va être mise en place mais je ne partage
pas la totalité de votre point de vue et
donc pas forcément je dirais tous les
attendus de la Cour des comptes je crois
qu'aujourd'hui parfois malheureusement
nos modes de vie font que le droit est
finalement dépassé en en tous les cas
dans la pratique et en vitesse par les
pratiques et il faudrait donc à mon avis
essayer d'y remédier et de maintenir
c'est raison pour laquelle je propose de
maintenir cet
amendement je mets donc au monsieur
Longuet
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'intervention de de Jean-François
Husson est est
pertinente sa solution ne l'est
peut-être
pas son intervention est pertinente
parce qu'en effet le le monde
d'aujourd'hui
est la société civile est différente
plus complexe la vie s'allonge les les
rencontres se font et se défond sans
nécessairement passer en effet par des
statuts de droit et et les banquiers
comme d'ailleurs sans doute les
assureurs sont confrontés à un problème
simple ou bien il ils investiguent dans
la vie privée de leurs clients pour
disposer de de tous les éléments
d'information nécessaire et ils
apparaîtront un moment ou un autre pour
l'immense majorité de nos
compatriotes comme des prestataire qui
compliquent inutilement et excessivement
leur métier
ou bien ils ne le font pas mais s'ils ne
le font pas peut-on leur reprocher de ne
pas être en mesure de restituer la comp
excité d'une vie longue qui a pu passer
par des
étapes
conjugales ou amical ou familial qui ont
été consolidé juridiquement ou qui ne
l'ont pas été c'est une véritable
interrogation c'est la raison pour
laquelle une fois n'est pas coutume
chers collègues je je ne voterai pas
votre amendement parce que je crois que
le problème posé est complètement
légitime mais le risque s'il était
adopté c'est que les banques décident à
ce momentlà de se substituer aux
administrations à l'état civil au
notairire et de reconstituer elle-même
des fichers de la vie la vie des
personnes ce qui n'est pas le souhait en
général on aimerait qu'un qu'un banquier
répondre aux questions qu'on lui pose et
ne nous pose pas des questions qu'on n
pas envie auxquelles on n pas envie de
lui
répondre monsieur Moret pour explication
de vote
oui merci monsieur président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues moi je
votterai cet amendement parce que je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure ce que je
reproche et j'aurai l'occasion de de de
le redire tout au long de ces débats ce
que je reproche à ce texte c'est que
finalement on règle une partie du
problème c'est qu'on évite que les
sociétés d'assurance et les banques
gardent de manière indue des sommes dans
leur dans leur coffre si on peut dire ou
sur leur compte mais on a plus le souci
de faire en sorte que ça que ça aille
dans les caisses de l'État que d'aller
au au au bénéficiaaires et et l'argument
du du rapporteur général que j'ai noté
et et de ce point de vue-là tout à fait
éloquant quand le rapporteur général dit
on a déjà imposé de nombreuses
obligations par ce texte aux banques
j'ai envie de dire et alors est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est là pour essayer de ne
pas trop froisser les banques qui
expliquerait d'ailleurs que on a appris
il y a quelques instants que la
Fédération française des banques et la
Fédération française des sociétés
d'assurance est daigné donner leur
imprimature à ce texte ce qui est plutôt
de nature à m'inquiéter donc dire il
faut pas aller trop loin faut pas trop
contrarier les banques et les sociétés
d'assurance certes je le sais je l'ai
dit dans mon discours dans la discussion
générale on se horte en la matière à un
lobby qui est fort mais on n'est pas là
pour tenir compte me semble-t-il du du
lobby des assurances et des banques on
est là pour essayer de faire en sorte
que les épargnants puissent bénéficier
des fonds qui leur revientent les
épargnants et leurs ayant droit et ça a
été largement souligné par le rapporteur
général et et par le par le ministre il
y a eu des abus les sociétés d'assurance
et les banques ont ont commis de graves
manquements pendant des années des
décennies ils ont fait en sorte de
garder des sommes indues et je suis un
petit peu choqué qu'on puisse encore
dire comme l'a fait le rapporteur
général on a on impose déjà beaucoup
d'obligations aux banques on va
peut-être s'arrêter là aujourd'hui donc
même si effectivement cet amendement
peut poser des des difficultés
d'application parce que effectivement la
banque ne connaît pas forcément les a
droits peut-être qu'on pourrait
sous-amender en mettant les les a en
droit lorsqu'ils sont connus mais sur le
principe sur pardon sur le principe
d'essayer de de de rechercher à la fois
les bénéficiaires et leors ayant droit
je suis évidment tout à fait d'accord et
c'est le sens de tous les amendements
que j'ai proposé tout à l'heure donc je
voterai cet amendement bien je mets donc
au voix cet amendement 40 monsieur le
rapporteur général
oui juste un mot monsieur le Président
pour répondre à l'argument utilisé par
Mor lorsque j'ai dit que on imposait des
déjà beaucoup de d'obligations aux
banques c'était pas dans mon intention
de dire on impose déjà beaucoup de
choses et on va pas charger la barque de
façon supplémentaire c'est pas dans cet
esprit là que je l'ai dit j'ai indiqué
que toutes les exigences nouvelles
formulé à l'intention des banques avait
vocation à résoudre le problème posé
pour l'essentiel et que dès lors on
était en mesure d'avancer d'une façon
tout à fait efficace d'autant que
aujourd'hui lui
avec l'action des notaires et l'ensemble
du dispositif je pense que on est en
mesure de répondre très largement à
l'exigence qui est formulé enfin
deuxième chose je voulais dire que il ne
s'agit pas dans mon esprit de dire que
c'est un texte qui va surtout servir les
intérêts de l'État parce que il s'agit
bien de la protection des épargnants des
déposants et des ayant droit des des
compte d'assurance vie et si ce
dispositif marche bien et ben il y aura
pas beaucoup d'argent au bout des 30 ans
à aller dans les caisses de l'État et
c'est bien pour que ce dispositif marche
bien qu'on essaie de trouver des
dispositions qui soient d'une grande
efficacité et si ça marche bien c'est
vrai qu'il restera peu d'argent pour
aller vers les comptes de l'État et donc
je pense qu'il n'est pas opportun
d'anticiper l'utilisation qui pourrait
être faite de cet argent parce que si
cette PPL est pleinement efficace comme
on le souhaite et ben l'argent va aller
aux destinataires aux ayant droit et aux
héritiers et on aura ainsi je crois bien
répondu à l'exigence il nous est formulé
qui est de protéger les intérêts de des
épargnants et des ayants droits je ne
vois pas d'autres demandes d'explication
de vote cette fois donc je mets au voix
le 40 rectifié bis qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'amendement n'est
pas à
adopté le 4 rectifié bis n'est pas
défendu nous en venons au 20 rectifiés
présentés par Monsieur
Moret merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je viens d'écouter le le rapporteur
général me répondre et dans ce qu'il a
dit je vois des des arguments qui vont
le convaincre d'apporter un avis
favorable à cet amendement parce que il
a indiqué que l'objet de ce texte était
je le cite la protection des épargnants
il a affirmé sa volonté que ça marche
bien et il a affirmé sa volonté surtout
que les sommes en question aillent au
destinataire et bien si on veut que les
sommes qui sont sur les comptes inactifs
puisque l'article 1er porte sur les
comptes inactifs si on veut que les
sommes qui sont sur les compes inactifs
aillent à leur bénéficiaire et bien je
crois qu'il faut très clairement
inscrire l'obligation de recherche parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est
peut-être le plus le plus incroyable
pour ne pas dire le le moins acceptable
dans le texte qui nous est soumis mis à
part sur les contrats d'assurance vie et
bien ce texte ne pose aucune obligation
de recherche des bénéficiaires des
contrats il y a simplement une
obligation d'informer les titulaires
mais pour les pour informer les
titulaires que le compte est inactif
encore faut-il qu'on le connaisse et
quand c'est pas le cas et bien il faut
qu'on le recherche et comme ça n'est pas
ce qui est proposé dans la proposition
de loi l'objet de cet amendement est
qu'en matière de compte inactif il y ait
une obligation de recherche du
titulaire monsieur le rapporteur général
quel est l'avis de la
commission l'avis de la commission le
président sera identique à l'avis que
j'ai donné préalablement puisque la
commission des finances a estimé que il
n'était pas opportun d'aller au-delà de
l'ensemble des mesures qui ont déjà été
prévues dans cette PPL en ce qui
concerne l'obligation de chercher les
titulaires et dans dans ces conditions
l'avis est défavorable pour les
arguments qui ont été avancés déjà
précédemment monsieur le ministre même
avis et donc je
suis
commentur une demande d'explication de
vote de Monsieur Longuet
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègue je vais
soutenir l'amendement de Monsieur Moret
le 20 rectifié mais je voudrais lui dire
deux choses première c'est qu'on peut
défendre des convictions sans
nécessairement défendre des intérêts des
lobbyes il se trouve que je défends
strès sincèrement le point de vue du
client de la banque qui risque si l'on
multiplie les obligations pesant sur la
banque d'être contraint le pour obtenir
le moindre prêt ou le le ouvrir le
moindre dépôt
de présenter des informations
innombrables dont certaines sont
particulièrement
personnel et qui n'a pas forcément envie
de livrer à son banquier et son banquier
fort de l'obligation qui aurait été
faite de retrouver tous les ayants droit
serait fondé à lui dire monsieur dans
ces conditions je ne vous ouvre pas de
compte ou je vous je ne vous consens pas
de facilité parce que vous n'êtes pas
pour moi transparent vous ne me
permettez pas de respecter une
obligation désormais une obligation
légale de retrouver voilà donc c'est je
crois qu'il y a un malentendu cher
collègue je
défendais le client de la banque et non
pas la banque elle-même qui est tout à
fait capable de se défendre toute seule
je pense en revanche que l'enfer est
souvent pavé de bonnes intentions et
qu'à vouloir trop protéger on donne à au
plus puissant en l'occurrence la banque
les raisons de ne pas satisfaire des
demandes individuelles beaucoup plus
simple en revanche mais il y a une forme
de totologie mais pour dissipuer toute
ambiguité lorsque vous proposez à
l'alinéa 13 de compléter par ce compte
recherche et en informe bah il est
évident que pour informer il faut
rechercher c'est une forme de totologie
mais si ça vous fait plaisir et pour
dissiper toute ambiguité je vote de bon
cœur votre amendement parce que pour
informer il faut rechercher et en effet
rechercher un titulaire me paraît une
relation acceptable entre une banque et
son client mais rechercher les ayant
droit du titulaire ça devient un petit
peu plus compliqué et c'est pas le
travail du banquier sauf à lui permettre
ou plutôt à l'obliger de rassembler des
documents qu' n'a pas vocation à
gérer bien j'ai été saisi d'e demande de
scrutin public par le groupe udi UC sur
l'amendement numéro 20 rectifié je vous
rappelle que l'avis de la commission est
des favorable l'avis du Gouvernement
également il va donc être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement et
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est
ouvert
suriss
plus personne ne demande à voter donc le
scrutin est clos et j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au
dépouillement
bien résultat du scrutin 175 sur
l'amendement numéro 20 rectifié nombre
de votants
392 nombre de suffrages ex 342 pardon et
là c'est 40 aussi 34 ou ah tu faire les
Quates un peu bien 340 suffrage exprimé
pour l'adoption 69 contre 271 le Sénat
n'a pas
adopté je suis saisi maintenant de deux
amendements en discussion commune tout
d'abord le premier présenté par Monsieur
Moret de 14
rectifiés et un sous-amendement ensuite
oui merci monsieur le Président euh cet
amendement propose que l'information des
ayants droit se fasse par courrier
recommandé par tout autre moyen à sa
disposition cette formule est celle qui
est utilisée à l'article 4 où il est
donc prévu que pour les contrats
d'assurance vie l'in formation se fera
de de cette manière et donc il nous
semble logique que pour les les comptes
inactifs l'information puisse également
se faire par courrier
recommandé bien monsieur le rapporteur
vous nous présentez le 74 et en même
temps je pense vous allez nous donner
votre avis
sur Oui monsieur président merci
l'amendement comme il vient d'être dit
vise à préciser que l'information des
titulaires de comptes inactifs par les
banques au moment du constat
d'inactivité est réalisé par courrier
recommandé nous sommes interrogés sur la
nécessité du courrier recommandé et dès
lors nous avons estimé que si
l'amendement apportait une précision
utile en rppelant l'information des
titulaires du caractère inactif doit
être réalisé par tout moyen comme pour
le reste du
texte bon par moment il n'y a pas encore
transfert des avoir qui reste au sein du
compte bancaire il ne semble peut-être
pas utile d'alourdir cette procédure par
un courer recommandé
en revanche monsieur Moret présente
d'autres amendements précisant
l'obligation d'un courrier recommandé
auquel je donnerai un avis favorable dès
lors qu'il s'agit d'étape décisive dans
la procédure en particulier pour le
transfert la caisse de dépôts et
consignation ou à l'état et donc dans
ces conditions la commission des
finances a considéré que on pouvait
peut-être alléger le dispositif et le
sous-amendement à cette
vocation dans la mesure où il s'agit
seulement du constat d'inactivité et non
d' transfert des avoirs àa et dépôts ou
à l'état il ne sent pas nécessaire de
prévoir l'envoi d'un courrier recommandé
c'est l'objet du sousamendement numéro
74 et dans ces conditions si le
sousendement étaé accepté nous serions
favorabl à l'adoption de l'amendement de
Hervé
MAEt monsieur le ministre quel est votre
avis sur l'amendement et le
sous-amendement je partage totalement
l'avis qui vient d'être donné par le
rapporteur général du budget et sa
proposition de sous-amendement donc sous
condition de l'adoption de ce
sous-amendement le gouvernement
donnerait un avis favorable à
l'amendement monsieur de lâre pour
explication de
vote monsieur le Président nous avons
soutenu hein ce la combinaison des deux
amendements commission des finances l'un
complétant l'autre d'une façon tout à
fait alors pour expliquer aussi le vote
précédent en réalité il y avait un
d'amendements des uns des autres qui
précise un peu les choses alors notre
problème c'était de ne pas trop alourdir
et de de conserver ce qui était vraiment
efficient dans le dispositif il faut
quand même comprendre que les comptes
bancaires non mouvementé au bout de 1 an
vont être ou déclaré inactif vont être
remis à à la Caisse des dépôts et
conciliation qui va émettre un fichier
donc nous ça nous a semblé le fichier la
la garantie de consultation par ailleurs
il faut bien dire que il s'agit des
endroits les droits ils na'issent pas
comme ça au coin du bois les doits les
droits il sont issu en général d'un
contrat enfin d'une situation qui ou qui
faitre des droits donc ça nous
paraissait être un compromis entre la
nécessité quand même et la liberté qu'a
indiqué mon collègue gérrard Longuet et
la nécessité effectivement d'avoir les
moyens que de de faire en sorte que la
banque fasse ce qu' ce qu'on souhaite
qu'elle fasse à travers les textes que
nous sommes en train de voter donc c'est
un c'est un espèce d'équilibre que nous
avons trouvé en commission donc nous
défendrons nous en
permanence la à la fois les amendements
qui ont été retenus hein qui sont
souvent les amendements qui sont
d'origine de Monsieur Morel qui ont été
complétés en commission pour faire en
sorte qu'on aboutisse à un texte à la
fois non
totalement on va dire parce qu'on dit
toujours la loi est trop bavarde il faut
bien dire aussi il y a aussi des décrets
d'application derrière qui peuvent
préciser son des choses donc le ministme
peut nous dire à l'occasion euh bon je
je préciserai dans un texte
d'application mais on peut pas non plus
rallonger sans arrêt et se faire
critiquer en permanence que la loi est
bavarde donc c'est un un espèce de
compromis de Commission d' travail de
commission qui nous apparaît équilibré
donc le groupe UMP défendra cette
position tout au long des amendements
d'une nature assez voisine bien je
monsieur
Moray
oui merci monsieur le Président je je
suis évidemment pas d'avis de du même
avis que le rapporteur général parce que
si j'ai bien compris rapporteur Gal dit
c'est pas la peine de faire un courrier
commandé parce que c'est pas c'est pas
un moment très important de de la vie du
compte c'est pas un moment très
important de la procédure je trouve que
le moment où on va dire au titulaire
d'un compte que son compte a été
identifié comme inactif c'est quand même
un moment important c'est un moment fort
c'est le moment à partir duquel le le le
compte àbour va commencer avant un
transfert vers la Caisse des dépôts et
et vers l'état donc je peux pas admettre
l'argument qui est de dire c'est pas
très important surtout que faire une
lettre recommandée ça n'est pas non plus
très astraignant ça n'est pas non plus
très lourd ça n'est pas non plus très
contraignant par pour les établissements
bancaires que l'on souhaite je l'ai bien
compris cet après-midi ménager donc moi
je je n'accepte pas ce sous-amendement
qui qui revient finalement à à supprimer
l'amendement puisque l'objet de
l'amendement c'est deett par courrier
recommandé on a repris la formule qui
est à l'article 4 et donc on a mis et
par tout autre moyen à disposition et là
on supprime l'aspect courrien recommandé
donc ça ça équivaut à revenir quasiment
à la version qui est dans la proposition
de loi donc je ne suis pas favorable à
ce sous-amendement je diraiis à mon
collègue de lâre qui a bien voulu
revenir sur le vote précédent et et et
donner quelque part une explication par
rapport à la position de l'UMP qui
effectivement m'a surprise parce que
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure mon collègue
Longué dire qu'il soutenait cet
amendement qui encore une fois avait
pour but de décrire clairement que l'on
devait rechercher les bénéficiaires de
comp inactif comme on doit le faire pour
les bénéficiaires de contrat d'assurance
vie ce qui me paraît normal si on veut
préserver les droits des des des
titulaires de comptte et c'est ce
qu'avais dit jarlonguer donc je
m'attendais à un autre vote du groupe
UMP j'ai compris en écoutant mon
collègue de lâre je je dirais pas qu'il
y ait un accord UMPS je je laisserai ce
type d'argument à d'autres mais les
faits sont là et j'ai en revanche bien
noté que Monsieur de lâre et le groupe
UMP considérait que ce qui avait été
fait en commission était parole
d'évangile et que donc l'UMP et le PS
étaient d'accord ensemble pour voter
tous les amendements qui n'avaient pas
eu la sacro 5 bénédiction de la
commission des des finan c'est une
attitude dont je prends acte bien je
mets
au non vous je suis désolé monsieur
delâre je mets au voix l'amendement le
sous-amendement 74
qui est
pour le sous-amendement 74 qui est pour
contre qui s'abstient donc le
sous-amendement est adopté je mets au
voix l'amendement lui-même le 14
rectifié ainsi amendé qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
l'amendement ainsi amendé est adopté n
en revenons à la même configuration avec
un amendement 29 rectifié euh présenté
par Monsieur Moret et un sous-amendement
ensuite à l'objet de cet amendement il
rejoint la préoccupation qu'avait
exprimé tout à l'heure mon collègue
guuson c'est que l'on essaie de
retrouver non seulement les les les
ayants droits et les personnes habilités
pardon l'on essaie de retrouver pas
seulement les les personnes habilités et
les titulaires mais aussi les ayant
droit parce que encore une fois quand on
veut défendre les épargnants on se
soucie aussi de rechercher les ayant
droit bien Monsieur Marc monsieur le
rapporteur général vous nous proposez
donc le sous-amendement 73 en même temps
que votre avis
sur oui alors sous réserve de l'adoption
du sous-amendement 73 la commission des
finances est favorable à cet amendement
qui permet de prévoir une information
des ayants droit dès lors que la banque
aurait directement connaissance de
l'existence d'un héritier du titulaire
décédé et le sous-amendement prévoit que
les établissements de crédit ne peuvent
être tenus d'informer des aant drroit
dont il n'auraiit pas connaissance le
présent sous-amendement vise donc à
préciser que les établissements doivent
informer les endroits s'ils les
connaissent par exemple lorsqu'il s'agit
d'enfant du titulaire également client
ou ancien client de l'établissement donc
on est en cohérence avec la position
adoptée ici en cohérence avec les
arguments développés pour le les
précédents à ne pas faire une
investigation généralisée mais à se
restreintre
des ayant droit dont on a clairement
identifié le lien familial avec les
intéressés min même avis je présume
bien bien je mets donc au voix le
sousam vous souhaitez intervenir
monsieur
deâre je suis quand même heureux
d'apprendre par un cègue de l'UDI je
suis passé dans dans l'opposition
constructive alors
le je pense que le travail en commission
est important et si le le représentant
de du groupe udi nous a exposé la
position on aurait pu réfléchir il je
regrette j'étais en commission avec
unemble d'entre vous ça pas été le cas
donc quand on on se met d'accord en
commission c'est pas pour changer d'avis
en séance public enfin c'est pas ma
façon de travailler et tout le monde
sait naturellement que je suis un un un
virulant des défenseur de l'umpps alors
je je simplement dire à Monsieur le
Ministre sur un certain nombre de de de
de disposition quand on dit nous on
s'est rallé au rapporteur général parce
que par tout moyen pourquoi parce queil
y a d'autres moyens que la lettre
recommandée aujourd'hui tout le monde
sait ça qui vaut qui en droit à la même
conséquence hein tout le monde sait que
nous sommes quand même dans le numérique
he quelque part donc c'est c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous nous avons
trouvé que c'était un bon amendement
alors en plus je demanderai au ministre
si parfois de façon à ce qu'on ait des
lois plus concises
plus il n pourrait pas prendre quel
quelques engagements pour dire dans les
textes d'ubication on dira les moyens
c'est le mail voilà et comme ça mon
collègue je pourrais à nouveau le
croiser dans les couloirs de du Sénat et
qui me sert la marche
alheureusement bien monsieur Moret vous
souhaaitiez intervenir je pense joui je
vais d'abord rassurer monsieur del lâre
il n'est pas dans mes intentions de ne
plus lui serrer la main et de ne plus le
saluer je tiens à le dire publiquement
euh concernant le sous-amendement que
propose le rapporteur général celui-ci
me paraît tout à fait de mon point de
vue acceptable j'accepte bien volontiers
que l'on précise le fait que l'on ne
peut rechercher les ayant droit que dans
la mesure où ils sont connus de
l'établissement et j'y vois un début
peut-être d'attitude un tout petit peu
plus ouverte de la part des commissions
de la la commission des finances dont on
sait bien que c'est une commission
puissante et que Monsieur del lat l' l'a
dit une fois que c'est débattu en
commission des finances tel qu' l'a dit
si j'ai bien compris les autres
sénateurs qui n'ont pas la chance de
faire partie de cette noble commission
n'ont plus leur moi dire mais je ne suis
pas sur cette ligne rassurez-vous merci
Monsieur le présent donc bien je mets au
voix le sous-amendement 73 qui est pour
le sous-amendement
73 qui est contre qui s'abstient le
sousamendement est adopté je mets
maintenant le l'amendement ainsi am
sous-amendé au voie même vote je suppose
je vous remercie il est adopté ensuite
un amendement 23 rectifié présenté par
Monsieur MAEt
toujours bien merci beaucoup cet
amendement que je que j'ai repris
également pour d'autres parties du texte
à d'autres articles du texte c'est un
sujet que j'avais déjà évoqué dans la
proposition de de loi que j'avais déposé
en en 2010 et qui n'avait pas été retenu
d'ailleurs par la à la Commission à
l'époque justement parce que déjà à
l'époque on m'avait dit qu'il fallait
avancer progressivement et que c'était
peut-être trop d'un coup imposé au
société d'assurance l'objet de cet
amendement c'est que l'on ait une
meilleure information et une plus grande
transparence sur ce que l'on appelle les
NPAI les NPAI c'est les n'habit pas à
l'adresse indiquée tous les ans vous
avez des courriers qui reviennent à leur
expéditeurs c'est les sociétés
d'assurance ou les banques avec la
mention n'habite pas ou n'habite plus à
l'adresse indiquée parce que soit la
personne concernée a déménager soit
parfois même dès l'origine il y a eu un
mauvaise une mauvaise saisie de
l'adresse du du souscripteur et j'en
suis personnellement témoin puisque ça
fait pas loin de 20 ans que j'ai
souscrit un contrat d'assurance c'est
pas un contrat d'assurance vie je vais
tout vous dire c'est un contrat
d'assurance retraite complémentaire 3è
pilier que j'avais souscrit dans ma vie
professionnelle depuis l'origine il y a
une mauvaise adresse en ce qui me
concerne et donc quand je remets mes
dossiers de retraite à jour chaque fois
je me dis tiens j'ai pas mon relevé
chaque fois j'appelle la compagnie je ne
donnerai pas le nom rassurez-vous je
donne mon adresse et ça n'est jamais
fait donc ça montre bien que même quand
on signale aux sociétés d'assurance
elles ne sont pas toujours très très
porté sur la rectification des adresses
et si on avait une information sur le
sujet c'est-à-dire si tous les ans on
savait ce que représente le volume des
NPI concerné établissement par établ
issement les recherches qui ont été fait
et et les et ce qu'elles ont donné ça
permettrait déjà d'avoir une plus grande
transparence sur le phénomène et puis ça
permettrait aussi que les sociétés
d'assurance et les banques ne perdent
pas de vue des clients et ainsi que l'on
évite de se retrouver lorsque le compte
est inactif au moment d'une d'une
succession à avoir des des gens qui ont
été complètement perdus de vue en clair
ça permet d'avoir un suivi plus régulier
des titulaires des
comptes monsieur le rapporteur général
quel est l'avis de la commission
la Commission a bien compris monsieur le
Président les les intentions de notre
collègue harvé
Moret comprend bien l'esprit de ce qui
est proposé mais la Commission s'est
demandé si ceci avait sa place dans la
loi
et nous avons estimé que le ministre
pourrait sans doute nous confirmer que
le décret prévoira une publicité
détaillée ce qui pourrait permettre à
notre collègue de retirer son amendement
si cet engagement a été pris concernant
tous les éléments de publicité qui vont
être précisés dans le décret voilà la
position de la Commission des finances
monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président ça me
permet de répondre bien entendu à votre
amendement monsieur le sénateur mais en
même temps aux préoccupations exprimées
par Monsieur
deâre
qui avec qui j'ai des relations amicales
mais qui ne m'oblige pas à avir une
alliance politique aussi serrée que
celle que vous présumiez monsieur le
sénateur
euh oui il est évident que dans la loi
on met les principes et que dans les
décrets on met un certain nombre de
précisions et d'élément d'application
c'est vrai pour répondre aux
préoccupations qui ont été exprimées par
Monsieur delâre dans sur les amendements
précédents c'est vrai s'agissant aussi
de votre amendement donc les critères
qui concernent les informations à
produire par les établissements
bancaires y compris celle-là relève
évidemment du domaine du règlement et
seront donc déterminés par décret avec
un souci affirmé d'une information de la
plus complète possible et la plus
efficace
possible bien monsieur Moret
oui merci monsieur le Président je je
suis pas tout à fait convaincu par
l'argument je vois pas pourquoi faire la
transparence sur le phénomène des NPAI
serait du domaine réglementaire alors
que faire la transparence sur les
contrats recherché et les encours en
question serait du domaine de la loi ça
j'avoue que j'ai pas la même lecture des
articles 34 et 37 de la Constitution que
que le ministre est rapporteur général
ceci dit pour montrer que à mon collègue
de lâre qu'au centre on est beaucoup
plus ouvert que sur ces ban surtout sur
le sien je suis prêt à retirer mon
amendement si si monsieur le ministre
vous êtes plus précis dans votre
engagement parce que vous avez dit que
le décret apporterait plein de précision
moi j'aimerais que vous me disiez j'ai
confiance je vous accorde le bénéfice du
doute pas dire que j'ai confiance en
vous c'est ve dire que j'accorde le
bénéfice du doute si vous dites très
clairement que dans le décret il y aura
des des obligations
relative à une meilleure connaissance et
une meilleure prise en compte du
phénomène de ce qu'on appelle les NPAI
les n'habit pas adresse indiqué si vous
voulez bien clairement le le dire alors
je retirerai mon
amendement je suis très clair je croyais
avoir été suffisamment clair mais
puisque je ne l'ai pas été je reprends à
mon pour moi les propos qui ont été les
vôtres dont j'espère qu'ils se
traduiront dans des conditions
correspondantes à votre volonté dans le
futur
décret l'amendement 23 qui est donc
retiré par Monsieur Moret et nous en
venons à l'amendement 33 présenté par
Monsieur boet
oui très Brument monsieur le Président
nous considérons que l'imputation de
frais de gestion à un compte réputé
inactif nous paraît tout à fait
injustifié voire insolite en effet les
les avoirs déposés sur des comptes
réputés inactifs constiue pour la banque
une épargne gratuite qui leur permet de
travailler de financer et donc de
dégager de l'intérêt donc de la valeur
et de l'actif donc nous considérons que
la rémunération déjà existe
euh puisqu'on parle d'un milliard de de
dépôts à peu près sur ces comptes
inactifs ça n'est pas une somme
négligeable et si les comptes dorment
parfois j'ai l'impression que l'argent
lui est frappé de d'insomni donc nous
considérons qu'il serait tout à fait
injustifié d'imputer les frais de
gestion à un compte qui ne vit pas
monsieur le rapporteur générale quel est
l'avis de la commission la commission
est défavorable car la gestion d'un
compte même inactif induit des frais
minimaux qu'il est normal de
rémunérer qu'ient de souligner que la
gestion d'un compte même lorsqu'il est
inactif comporte des frais pour le
teneur du compte par exemple en terme de
conservation documentaire de
vérification régulière de l'état du
compte et puis en dernier ressort la
commission l'a évoqué ce matin les frais
sont doublement limités par le texte de
la proposition déjà en elle-même puisque
les frais d'inactivité sont plafonnés et
que d'autrees part part le transfert à
la Caisse des dépôts qui intervien un
délai de 3 ans seulement après le décès
du titulaire entraîne par définition
l'arrêt du prélèvement de tout fr
bancaire donc je crois que dans l'esprit
on répond implicitement déjà dans le PPL
à à ce qui est votre préoccupation mais
au demeurant je pense qu'il y a une
certaine légitimité à ce que un compte
même inactif puisse donner lieu à
quelques rémunération puisque il y a des
tâches courantes à effectuer concernant
ces comptes donc avis défavorable
monsieur ministre
oui mê mon opinion monsieur le Président
euh plafonner oui plafonner d'ailleurs
fermement oui c'est nécessaire parce que
il y a eu des abus par le passé que vous
connaissez que nous connaissons et nous
voulons y mettre fin tous ensemble
plafonner oui mais considérer qu'il n'y
a strictement aucun et par principe
aucun frais sous prétexte que le texte
que le compte serait inactif je pense
queon va au-delà du du raisonnable donc
plafonner fermement oui interdire ma
réponse est non et si vous étiez
convaincu par mes arguments je pense
qu'il serait bon que vous puissiez
retirer cet
amendement monsieur boet non monsieur le
minist je ne suis pas convaincu par vos
arguments donc je maintiens le
l'amendement et conclurai en disant que
il y a quelque chose de dialectique à
créer de l'actif à partir d'inactif
voilà h bien je mets donc au voix
l'amendement
33 euh qui est pour l'amendement 33 qui
est contre qui s'abstient l'amendement
33 n'est pas adopté et le 13 rectifié
n'était pas défendu
euh nous en venons à l'amendement 41
rectifié bis qui est présenté par
Monsieur
Husson non monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il sera pas défendu
puisqu'il est dans le droit fil de du
rejet que nous avons essuyé tout à
l'heure et comme à mon avis nous
subirons le même échec on s'arrêtera là
donc l'amendement 41 rectifié bis est
retiré et le 5 rectifié bis n'est pas
défendu le 7 rectifié bis non plus et le
15 rectifié est présenté par Monsieur
maay
oui très rapidement c'est un amendement
qui tend là encore à introduire
l'information par voie de courrier
recommandé ou par tout autre moyen là
encore en reprenant la formule qui est
par ailleurs utilisée dans la
proposition de loi l'article 4 monsieur
général et bien monsieur le Président à
nos yeux il s'agit là effectivement d'un
moment important dans le processus
d'inactivité puisque des entraîne la
fermeture du compte ici dès lors il
semble utile que l'information utilire
soit transmise par courer recommandé la
commission est
favorable monsieur le
ministre bien je mets donc au voix
l'amendement 15 rectifié de Monsieur Mor
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement 15 rectifié est
adopté amendement 46 présenté par
Monsieur
Marc monsieur le
ministre je le mets au voix qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est
adopté le 6 rectifié bis n'est pas
défendu le 8 rectifié bis non plus le 21
rectifié présenté par Monsieur
Moret
bien ben écoutez je suis plus
persévérant plus tenace ou plus têtu
appelez ça comme vous voulez que mon
collègue hon même si je crains que cet
amendement est le même sort que celui
que j'ai présenté précédemment il tend
là encore à exprimer clairement qu'il y
a une obligation de recherche cette fois
non plus pour les bénéficiaires de de
compte inactif comme nous l'avons vu
précédemment mais en l'espèce pour les
bénéficiaaires de titulairire de coffre
fort parce que là encore je considère
qu'il faut rechercher les Bénéfic
officiè et pas seulement les
informer bien monsieur le rapporteur
général la commission est
défavorable à cet amendement monsieur le
Président chers collègue Moret parce que
euh l'amendement propose de mettre en
œuvre une obligation générale de nous
quittons l'hémicycle du Sénat mais nous
allons revenir sur l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi dans un instant c'est
le 24h Sénat
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de 24h Sénat voici les
titres la réforme territoriale doit-elle
passer par un référendum opposition
réclame une consultation populaire sur
ce sujet Alain Jupé l'ancien Premier
ministre met le gouvernement en garde
contre une évolution fédéraliste de la
France qui mettrait je cite en danger
l'unité du pays adoption au Sénat d'une
loi renforçant